Here we go.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
David,
Joe,
how are you sir?
Great,
thanks.
Thanks for being here man.
I appreciate it.
Thanks for having me on.
I'm really looking forward to talking to
you very much so.
This is a fascinating subject for me.
Anti aging.
The idea that you'll be able to stop
aging or even possibly pull it back or
if they're very least slowed down.
What do you think?
I think that's all on the table.
We've been doing this for years in the
lab.
Now we've just got to figure out how to
do it in people.
When I talk to someone like you as an
actual research scientists to this
stuff,
I always want to know what are you doing
to yourself?
How long have you got?
Like what do you do a daily basis?
I do.
Are you 100 years old?
Uh,
getting there.
How old are you?
20.
50.
So if you're turning 50 and I wouldn't
have thought you were 50,
I would have figured you were for about
41.
Forty two.
Oh,
that's kind of you.
One of my brothers,
the negative control and he's,
he's,
does he look like shit?
Well,
I can't say that,
but people say that he doesn't look as
young as me and he's about three and a
half years younger.
So what are you doing personally?
Uh,
well,
you know,
most of the time I'm in the lab and
trying to run a bunch of companies to
make these drugs are reality.
But daily I try to keep a healthy
weight.
I do intermittent fasting,
which is pretty easy because I'm so
busy.
I forget to eat.
How many hours do you give yourself
every night?
Uh,
well I suffer from a late night
snacking,
but I try to skip breakfast,
skip lunch if I'm busy.
So I'm a night eater,
but that seemed to be good because a
study came out about a couple of weeks
ago,
at least in mice that it's not what you
eat,
it's when you eat.
That's most important for longevity
really.
And when,
when being,
when like what's,
it doesn't actually matter if you eat a
lot in the morning or a lot at night.
I like nighttime eating,
but you need a period during the day at
least if you're a mouse,
probably if you're a human where you're
hungry,
um,
and that puts your body in a defensive
mode and these are the things that we've
been studying in my lab for the last 20
years.
What are the processes that died and
exercise do for us?
They keep us healthy and why does
calorie restriction and intermittent
fasting make animals live so much longer
and we think we figured out a large part
of how that works and now we're
mimicking that with molecules.
Um,
is the,
is the idea that you can mimic it with
molecules and it will be as effective as
intermittent fasting.
I think the molecules will be better.
And not only that,
when we add them onto a healthy diet and
exercise and the animals they do even
better.
It's like a supercharged mouse.
Now when you add them onto the mice,
do you also add them on with
intermittent fasting?
And is there an additional benefit?
Uh,
we do.
We do.
One of the first molecules that infants,
molecules that we are known for is
resveratrol from red wine.
That molecule discovered it in my
thirties,
or at least linked it to aging.
What we showed was that if you give it
to a fat mouse,
there was healthy as a thin mouse.
They live just as long.
They don't get heart disease and all of
the other bad stuff.
Then what we did was interesting.
We gave it to the mice either every day
in their food or let them skip a meal
every day so that they were fed every
other day.
And that combination of,
as virtual plus every other day feeding,
we had the longest lifespan we'd ever
seen.
And it was so.
It was additive.
Same with exercise.
If we give our latest molecule called
Ada men,
uh,
to a mouse and we exercise it,
it'll run even further than it could
with either of those alone.
So it's not an excuse to sit around and
just eat chips and watch TV.
It augments healthy lifestyle,
get you further than what you could get
naturally.
So in any,
are you seeing a benefit in addition?
So is the idea to compound all those
things together?
Exactly.
Right.
So you asked about myself.
So I,
I do,
I eat healthy,
I try to skip meals.
I also take supplements and in fact most
of my colleagues are in the field of
aging or anti aging us as people call it
a.
So I take nmn every morning.
What is an m,
n?
Good question.
So let me take a quick step back.
Uh,
so about 20 years ago a Lenny Guarente
and a team of us at mit discovered a set
of genes that control aging in yeast
cells,
just bruise east,
what you find in beer and bread.
And those genes are called Sirtuin.
And there are seven of them in our
bodies,
five and yeast.
And what they do is they protect all
organisms on the planet,
plants,
bacteria,
humans from deterioration and disease.
They're like the Pentagon.
They sense when we're hungry since when
we're exercising and they send out the
troops to defend us.
So when you,
when you put more of these genes into a
reseller or a mouse,
they'll live longer between five to 20
percent longer.
And so we think that these genes are
responsible for the effects of dieting
and exercise,
which is great,
which what that means is we can now
mimic that with molecules.
So nmn is one of those molecules.
So Israel is virtual.
You can think of where as virtual as the
accelerator pedal for the Sirtuin genes.
And the sentiment is the,
is the fuel and without fuel reserve
virtual weren't works.
Nmn is the gas in the car I've heard of
resveratrol.
But as Nmn and new molecules is
commercially available,
some people started selling it on the
Internet as it related to an R,
which is sold by a bunch of companies.
And our year nicotine,
my driver's side is a supplement that
raises the levels of a molecule called
Nad feel like I should make a shopping
list.
So they get up here.
And so what are you writing that down to
that?
So the Sirtuins okay,
get this.
So sauternes need nad to work without
them.
Uh,
they're at work.
In fact,
if you don't have an ID in your body,
you'd be dead in about 30 seconds.
It's a really important molecule.
But as we get older,
we lose nad.
So by the time you're 50,
like I almost am,
you have about the half the levels of
once or you had when you were 20.
So that's not.
And these are two ends,
they don't protect the body without high
levels of Nad.
So what Nmn does and this other molecule
called nr,
which both you can get on the Internet,
they boost the body's levels of Nad
backup to youthful levels again,
and if we give them to mice,
these molecules t two mice Orient Worms
or yeast,
they live longer and they're super
healthy.
Now,
what level or how many milligrams are
you taking of these things?
Uh,
so yeah,
and a man is,
is um,
something I get from,
for myself,
I'm not selling anything.
So I take a gram of vitamin in the
morning based on clinical trials has
been shown that that will raise nad with
or without food.
Um,
I take a little bit of yogurt that I
make myself at home just to see,
uh,
you have been doing this for a while.
Uh,
and uh,
I only started doing stuff when I say
work in animals first.
So take,
take the yogurt mix in some ers.
Virtual research role is great,
but it's really insoluble.
It's like brick dust.
So in the yoga it'll dissolve.
Take another half a gram of reserve and
how much?
A half a gram.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's a powder.
I have a few kilos leftover from
clinical trials in my basement.
So yeah,
that's going to last me a few decades.
Uh,
and then I also take at night some
metformin,
which is probably the most radical thing
that I take,
which is a prescribed drug for diabetes.
Metformin met,
met him,
met and prescribable drug.
So you,
but you don't have diabetes?
I do not.
But you take it for,
for preventing cancer,
heart disease,
Alzheimer's and aging met.
Can you spell it?
Met F o r m I n
N.
and so studies have 10,000 people and
more.
It's been shown that people who take
metformin and even if they have diabetes
are protected against other diseases of
aging,
even frailty.
And so most scientists,
if you ask them in my field,
will say,
metformin is likely to extend your
lifespan.
It's just that the FDA doesn't let you
have it for aging because aging isn't a
disease yet.
So do you have to get diabetes to get it
or do you have to get a sneaky doctor?
Well,
I wouldn't call it sneaky doctor,
but the doctor typically has to be
convinced because they don't keep up
with the literature and it's off label.
Okay,
alright.
And how much do you take of that?
Uh,
I take a gram of that as well,
which is about a,
a low dose as some diabetics type two
grams.
So it's not crazy amounts.
Is there any side effects?
Well,
the good news is that it's extremely
rare that you get sick from any of these
molecules.
I'm in millions of patients around the
world.
Nobody's getting sick.
The worst you'll have as far as I can
tell is a stomach upset.
Um,
and I get that which is actually helpful
if I'm hungry or I lose my appetite.
But,
uh,
I think the downside is extremely low
and that the upside is,
you know,
anything's better than what's coming and
what is the mechanism that metformin is
operating.
So that,
so this is the great thing is that over
the last 20 years we have figured out,
we scientists have figured out that
there are universal regulators of aging
from yeast to worms to mice and in
treatments.
And there were three main pathways that
we figured out,
respond to what we eat,
how we exercise.
And one of them is called amp k a.
and this is a,
a target,
metformin.
And so I'm active.
When I take Metformin,
I'm activating my amp K,
which we'll send out the troops,
the Sir two ones I've mentioned.
That's the second of the pathways.
And so I take enemen and residual for
that.
And then third one is called
[inaudible],
which is a pathway in the body that
responds to how many amino acids,
how much meat you're eating.
And it will also protect the body if you
tweak it just the right way.
And as only besides eating low amounts
of protein,
the only way to,
to affect that pathways with a drug
called Rapamycin,
which is,
which is a little dangerous to try and
is used for a immunosuppressant.
So it's not something that I would
recommend a and I don't take it.
Wow.
So this is your daily routine along with
what,
what kind of Diet do you follow?
Well,
I,
I try to not eat too much.
It's pretty easy to overeat.
So I'd try to skip one or two meals a
day.
Um,
I avoid sugars and carbs.
I try to run once a week.
I do workouts on the weekend.
Like you,
I,
I love Saunas.
I like to put my body in some
temperature stress.
I go hate.
And then I jumped in a cold bath back
and forth that,
that works well for yeast.
We can do that in lab and they live 30
percent longer.
So
there's all that.
Do you have to try generally?
I normally.
Do you ever try going from Sauna to
cryotherapy?
Uh,
no.
I haven't tried actual cryotherapy.
Just a.
You haven't done it at all?
No.
You want to do it today?
Sure.
If he got one.
Yeah,
yeah.
We'll take you.
Take you down the street.
There's a great one because it's,
there's different kinds and some of them
are from the neck down.
Were they using liquid nitrogen?
The other ones,
they actually freeze the air.
So when they're using the nitrogen to
freeze the air and they're pumping in
air that's 240 degrees below zero and
you're,
you know,
you're going to do about two minutes.
I do three because I do it all the time,
but uh,
it's awesome.
I do three and then I take 10 minutes
off and then I go back in for another
three.
Yeah,
makes sense.
And what you're doing to your body when
you do that,
we think is to activate these longevity
pathways like this or two ends.
Yeah.
And uh,
and that's really the trick is to
activate your body's defenses against
aging.
I mean,
the old theories about aging,
you got to throw them out.
Most people at parties will tell you,
oh,
antioxidants,
free radicals,
DNA damage or mutations.
That is all for the most part,
incorrect
that antioxidants cause DNA damage.
No,
that's true.
That it repairs DNA damage.
Well,
intoxicants had been a rather big in the
aging
field,
but resveratrol and antioxidant,
correct.
Uh,
it's a mild antioxidant,
but it doesn't work by being an intox.
What does it work?
What is the pathway?
It steps on the accelerator pedal of the
Sirtuin enzymes.
And so it's directly controlling,
uh,
the body's defenses against aging.
So as we discussed it,
or as people discussed it as an
antioxidant,
it was just a mom,
a mild form of antibiotics,
an antioxidant,
but it didn't so much more.
Right?
And we know this because if you create a
yeast cell or a worm or a mouse,
and then you knock out the gene for the
Sirtuin,
now reversal doesn't help the animal
anymore.
That's interesting because when people
talk about wine,
that's the one thing they say.
There is very Charles and antioxidants
really good for you.
Yeah.
This is one of those urban myths that
never goes away and still fuels a
billion dollar industry.
But what we're finding is that the
molecules in plants like where's
virtual,
first of all that we think that produced
by plants,
because the plants are benefiting from
the stress,
we call it Hormesis,
a little bit of stress is good for you,
what doesn't kill you,
makes you stronger kind of thing.
And Hermes was discovered about 60,
70 years ago when people were spraying
herbicides on plants and a little bit of
herbicide actually made them stronger.
And we think that these molecules in
plants are similar.
They make the plant stronger during
times of stress.
So if you stress a grape that's for
winemaking,
you'll get great wine,
but you also get a lot of resveratrol.
And so when we ingest that resveratrol
from the clients,
we get the same health benefits because
the plants are activating their
serotonin pathways and we have the
[inaudible] and they activate us as
well.
Ah,
interesting.
Interesting.
So low carb,
low sugar,
um,
any specific type of protein?
Do you limit your amount of protein?
Yeah,
I mean I enjoy eating memos just as much
as anybody.
But,
um,
I try to avoid them for the main,
were two main reasons.
One is that,
uh,
there's this tmao molecule that seems to
cause heart disease.
Tmao.
Yeah.
Um,
and how's it linked to heart disease?
A disease epidemiology studies,
I forget,
but I do recall it.
The study was able to give the Tmao to
animals and they developed heart
disease.
So it's somehow causing it.
I forget exactly how it might be
damaging the genome.
That's my recollection with a omnivores
or predators.
Uh,
I think as red meat is the culprit,
right?
So are they giving us to rats are the
given this too?
It was a mouse study again,
so I mean mice might be different from
humans of course.
Uh,
but the other problem with,
with meat in general from,
from animals is that there's a lot of
noise in there and it's easy to eat a
lot of meat.
And so if you have high levels of mino
acids,
it will activate this mtor pathway,
one of those three longevity pathways.
And you don't want that.
You don't want that.
You don't want that because [inaudible]
has evolved to cents times of adversity
and stress and hunger.
So why do people see a performance
benefit when
they consume branch chain amino acids?
A really good question.
So in the short run,
just like taking testosterone,
it will give you performance benefits,
but we think in the long run it'll
actually come back to bite you.
So how will blend branched chain amino
acids come back to bite you.
So branch chain amino acids will
activate this mtor pathway.
Um,
and
when we do that in animals,
we actually,
we reduced their lifespan.
So it's the opposite.
You want to keep those levels low.
That's interesting that that seems,
I mean,
for a dummy like me,
it seems counterintuitive because it,
what's making you perform better.
Currently you would see,
you would think,
especially something like amino acids
and natural part of the human body,
you would think that that would be
beneficial.
You're adding to your body.
It's something that it needs.
Yeah,
you would.
But,
but what you should consider is that
it's a tradeoff off.
There's a theory that's probably
correct.
Uh,
it's the,
uh,
some Tom Kirkwood's terror theory called
the disposable Soma and our bodies want
to do one of two things,
either want to grow really fast and
reproduce fast,
build up a lot of muscle cells,
divide that's great.
In the short run,
you know,
you'd be fertile,
you can run,
but actually that set the expensive
hunkering down and building a long
lasting body and that's a tradeoff over
time.
And so animals that grow fast and
reproduce fast,
like a mouse will only have a short
lifespan.
Whereas a whale that grows slowly and
reproduced slowly will live a long time.
Interesting.
So
the idea is you're,
you're limiting your calories,
eliminating your carbohydrates,
you're limiting your protein,
you're limiting your amino acids,
but you're ramping up on all these
beneficial molecules,
right?
These,
these pathways that have evolved since
the beginning of life to make us live
longer during adversity so he can thrive
when times come back.
Do you take into consideration quality
of life versus length of life?
Like is there a sweet spot?
Yeah,
that.
Well,
it's hard to ask the mice how they feel,
but they,
we do test them and we do frailty
studies and we can see that they got
better memory and they can run further
on a treadmill.
The stronger those kinds of things they
see better and we think that that
probably means they're happier as well.
And when you're taking in protein,
so if you're not eating mammals,
are you eating a lot of fish?
Yeah,
fish is fine.
White meat.
I indulge A.
I like chipped in that kind of chickens,
fine.
I'm not too much of it,
but I'm trying to eat as many
vegetables,
especially the colored ones for the
reason that I said which is well,
a few reasons.
One is that you don't ingest as much
protein as you otherwise would.
You get all the vitamins,
but you also get those molecules from
plants that we think make you healthy.
So reserves will just one of a bunch of
polyphenols that plants make when
they're stressed and when plants are
stressed,
they go colored so that the purples and
the reds and blues,
yeah,
those are molecules that are generally
healthy and I think one of the few
scientists who thinks this,
but I think we've evolved as animals to
sense the plant world and when our food
supply is stressed out,
then our body's sense that bite when we
ingest them,
we get these molecules like virtual and
we've evolved to sense that and we get
the benefits of longevity as a side
effect.
And so
this is really fascinating to me because
the idea that you're trying to balance
out this,
the concept of a mouse growing very
quickly but dying quickly as well versus
something that can extend and live
longer and be more vital or have more
vitality for a longer period of time.
Well,
so here's the great thing is that now
that we've,
we believe,
we figured out why,
not just why,
but how this all works.
What are the genes and pathways in the
body that control this?
We can have our cake and eat it too.
We can at least in a mouse and probably
in a human in a few years' time,
and maybe even with the supplements
we'll see.
We can trick the body into being hungry
and being in adversity or even if you're
eating a lot or you're not exercising
and so we can turn slowly,
but eventually turning a mouse into more
like a human so that you,
even though you can grow and reproduce
quickly,
you still turn on these protective
pathways and live a long time.
The best example is the nematode worm,
artsy elegance.
It's been studied a lot for longevity
and the mutations that make those worms
live sometimes two and up to 10 times
longer are activating genes that are
normally only turned on when they
hunkered down and turn into a little
dour,
dour or a stage,
which means that they're.
They're not really reproducing,
they're just hibernating.
So you can have a hibernation of
benefits but still live a normal healthy
life.
And this is from manipulating genes.
Right?
So this all comes from genetics.
So I'm a geneticist at Harvard and the
way the breakthrough came,
so going back in the 19 eighties,
it was antioxidants mutations because
people really didn't have a handle on
what was going on and the idea that you
could slow down aging with one gene or
one drug was ludicrous because it's so
complicated,
but now we know from genetic studies is
that you can find mutations,
hundreds of them actually in organisms
that it linkedin lifespan.
So it's not as complicated as we
thought.
What about Myostatin inhibitors and the
studies that they've done with mice?
They turned them on and off and they've
grown those super mice.
Yeah.
Hock mice wellbeing.
A hulk doesn't mean you'll live longer,
right?
Didn't they live longer though?
I don't know.
Did they?
I believe they did.
I think that was one of the weird side
effects.
Well,
if you allow me to speculate as to why
that might've happened is so
being bulky is good,
let's find out what's correct for.
And Jamie will pull it up.
Well one of them,
but one of the things it bulky is good.
Bulky will increase your metabolism,
it'll get rid of the fat and the fat is
a real problem because fred fat will
make you inflamed.
Being fat is one of the worst things you
can you just fat shamed I did were very,
very upset at you right now.
Well,
build up muscle as well.
Some people are overweight and have a
lot of muscle and they're a lot better
off when you teach classes,
I assume I teach at Harvard.
Yeah.
And when you say that fat is bad,
do you get a new reaction over the last
couple of years?
Uh,
or do you,
do you find a way around saying it like
that you generally get okay.
Comments on my lectures,
but I wasn't saying fat people are bad
or saying having found in your vice
sells a bad.
Okay.
I like what you're saying.
So you're breaking it down to cells.
You're not picking on anybody here at
Myostatin.
Insufficiency produces 15 percent life
extension in mice.
So yeah.
So those milestone inhibitors make the
mice grow longer.
So you think that might have had an
effect by virtue of the fact that
they're more bulky and they have more
muscle tissue and they burn off more
fat.
That's one theory.
The other thing would be that so muscles
are secreting molecules called myokines
into the bloodstream and we don't know
what they all are,
but when you exercise,
you do release some of these and they
may also be contributing because muscles
are signaling to the whole body.
When you go for a run,
it's not that your muscles get an
exercise.
Everything in your body gets an exercise
by these communication molecules and
that's why if you fuse and old mouse to
young mouse,
you can have these benefits that the
young mouse and parts on the olden
actually negatively vice versa.
And when you save by fuse you mean by
taking the blood of the old mouse and
putting it into the young man?
Right?
But what we.
What we actually do,
because that's too hard.
You don't need humans,
but in mice what you do as you saw the
skin together so that the blood flows
between them.
Yeah.
It's not so pleasant,
but they don't seem to be too badly
affected once they learn how to walk in
sync.
Now,
by the way,
to all your listeners,
we don't do those experiments in my lab,
but when I say we,
I mean the scientific community as a
whole.
Um,
what,
what are your thoughts on if you have
any,
about the startups that are actually
taking the blood of young people and in
injecting it into the bodies of older
folks?
So I don't think there's a scientific
reason to say it won't work and the
scientists are involved or some of my
great colleagues,
very smart people.
Have you ever done it?
No.
That's a bit extreme for me,
but I think it could work.
It's just a little bit out there for me,
but what they're going to do,
what they're doing actually is treating
people with neurological disorders.
A lot of these startups,
and I'm involved in probably 15 startups
right now.
What we're trying to do is to treat
diseases of aging and even rare
childhood diseases because you can't
treat
it aging as a business model.
There is no disease called aging yet,
but anyway,
getting back to the science,
I think that it's based on solid
science,
but the future is,
is I think a better way to go about this
is to find what the actual molecules are
in the blood and just make those.
Don't give the whole kit caboodle.
Yeah.
When you said this twice,
you think aging is a disease or maybe
perhaps should be treated as a disease
or classified?
Oh,
absolutely.
Think aging should be classified as a
disease.
We should think of it as a disease.
I mean why?
Why shouldn't we?
Everything else that goes on in the body
over time that's bad for us is
considered a disease.
Do you know why aging isn't considered a
disease?
Because it happens to everybody?
Exactly.
That's the only reason.
Well,
it happens to most people.
Ninety percent of people in the
developed world,
but why is that a reason to say,
oh,
it's natural.
We should just deal with it.
We used to say that about cancer and we
used to say it about dying from an
infection.
When you say it happens to 90 percent of
the people in the developed world,
what happens?
The other 10,
they die.
He'd play a boss I guess.
Okay.
Let's see what you're saying.
So they die young.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just clarifying.
Yeah,
I agree.
I mean it's dis ease.
It's a problem,
right?
Aging is a problem with you.
I saw an old gentleman yesterday and it
was painful just to watch this poor guy
walk hunched over and just struggling to
move at an incredibly slow pace.
That seems like a person with the
disease.
Well,
it is.
And imagine if we were on a planet now
or you know,
an island where everybody leaves 300
years and we'd show up and you and I in
our midlife was signed to look older
already.
They're going to look at us and say,
what is wrong with you guys?
We need to treat you urgently.
We need to call this a new type of
syndrome.
And it's only because we all tend to go
through this that we think it's
acceptable,
but I would argue it's the biggest
threat to the healthcare system is the
biggest threat to the world's economy,
actually,
is the inability of us to treat people
in their old age and keeping them
healthy.
Mm.
Now some people look at it a different
way and their consideration is that
there's an overpopulation problem as it
is.
And folks like you want to walk around
living to be 300 years old,
have a gang of kids.
You could create a mess.
Right?
Well I have three kids.
That's enough.
That's more than I was going to have a.
But yeah,
it,
we do.
You have to do the math though.
How much with the population grow,
and
I'm actually working with a number of
people to try and calculate this.
A couple of economists in London that
we're working on.
So this is this really a problem.
I agree with you that if this comes in,
I would actually say when this comes,
when this comes is,
I mean it's coming as there's dozens of
companies working on drugs.
The sciences here,
so let's say it's coming anyway,
so we have to deal with how are we going
to deal with it?
Well,
let's first of all understand what the
future looks like.
We can't look backwards,
right?
Because no one's ever invented this
stuff before,
so we have to look forwards.
What's the world look like in terms of
population?
It's not as bad as you might think.
If you stopped aging today and everybody
just went on forever,
the population growth rate would be less
than the rate of immigration.
Now that's not.
I can't go on forever of course,
but what we find is as people healthier,
especially in developing nations,
they have fewer kids,
so the calculation shows that it would
eventually taper off,
so the human population will taper off
about nine to 10 billion people and then
stay there and that population will be
the happiest,
healthiest people in the world.
Now,
why do they predict that?
Because I was having this conversation
with someone the other day that as
people become more affluent and society
becomes more urban,
people will have less and less children
and the population will stabilize.
Is that the theory behind this?
Right.
And we'll actually education is a major
part of that as well.
Yeah.
Women's education is the main thing,
uh,
but also just being healthy or lifts
the,
the wealth of a nation.
And by women's education,
do you mean extended education so that
they,
the,
they pursue careers?
Is that
the,
the idea or is it,
I mean,
obviously most people understand
these are made like where?
Where's the education contributing to a
lower population?
Well,
so my understanding is that the first
thing you do,
if you,
if you educate young women,
is that they can make choices for
themselves and they are not just
subjugated,
uh,
you know,
most men would like to have more so,
right.
So you're thinking of like third world
and write the real developing world,
but that's where the population is a
real problem in Europe.
They actually are struggling to keep up
with their population,
know they've got an aging tsunami,
so to speak.
Same with Japan.
The average farmer in Japan is 65 years
old.
They got a real problem.
China's about to head that way too,
and that's going to drag the economy of
the planet down and it's gonna be a real
problem.
We're going to waste so much money on
keeping older people alive for the last
10,
20 years of their life with dementia.
Frailty,
that could be trillions of dollars,
just $50,000,000,000,000 just in this
country alone that could be spent on
figuring out how to solve global
warming,
better education,
the environment,
saving the one third species that are
becoming threatened.
That,
that's why I think tackling aging isn't
a selfish act.
It's probably the most generous Dec
action that I could give the planet.
That's an interesting way of looking at
it.
Um,
what populations as a whole,
you know,
when you look at the world,
um,
what,
where are the people living the longest
and why?
Well,
it's debatable.
There are these blue zones.
I think many of your listeners will have
heard about those.
Um,
but there are pockets that have great
genes,
but they also have great diets and
lifestyles.
And so the,
the best one that I'm familiar with is
the island of Okinawa in Japan.
And uh,
and by the way I used to follow the
Okinawan Diet,
a couple of my good friends wrote a book
about it,
so I was on to when some fish felt
really great,
couldn't keep it up,
but those,
why couldn't you keep it up?
I had kids and our meals turned into
pizzas and pasta.
Yeah,
unfortunately.
But I'm getting back there now that my
kids are teenagers,
but the Okinawans date,
they live into their hundreds of,
fairly frequently.
It's not one in a million.
It's more like one in 100,000 or
something.
So it's 10 times higher.
They,
they work most of their lives.
They physically active,
they fast a lot and they have a lot of
green leafy vegetables and that seems to
be the secret.
And there's,
uh,
there were,
there were selling something was
something about their mineral rich diet.
Remember they were selling,
it was like a big thing for awhile.
Coral calcium.
And they were using that as an example
of why the Okinawans were living so
long.
Do you remember that?
I do remember add,
yeah.
But in scientific circles we weren't
really bothered with it.
Yeah,
like there's calcium is calcium,
right?
Yeah.
I didn't know better,
better,
better calcium from coral or something.
I might even be wrong about that,
but I just remember reading about the
Okinawans and the speculation.
They seaweed as well.
Right?
Which is very healthy.
Probably the best thing that they do is
they don't overeat.
Stop at 70 percent.
Yeah,
I'm a glutton.
That's my number one problem.
I just love to eat.
Yeah.
Me Too.
I keep going once I'm in it,
I just want to just keep shoving it in
my face,
but I've done a good job over the last
few years of tapering that off and the
intermittent fast and I think is
probably one of the best things I've
ever done in terms of,
you know,
just maintaining energy levels,
maintaining body weight,
that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
You,
you look good.
So I think that that's one of the best
things that people can do.
What we've known for 70 or more years
actually as if you calorie restrict
animals actually even eat cells and
worlds.
They live longer and this is the most
robust way to to prevent cancer,
heart disease,
Alzheimer's in the mouse,
and so intimate and fasting is just a
way of me making this calorie restricted
diet.
So what is calorie restriction?
It's reducing what would your doctor
would recommend for your body,
but reducing it back to about 20 to 30
percent.
So it's quite extreme.
That's not pleasant.
I tried that for a week,
gave up too hard,
but intermittent fasting like yourself,
it's doable.
It's not always pleasant,
but uh,
I think that's the best way to do it.
And with the mice it works just as well
as calorie restriction,
which is pretty much always being a bit
hungry now.
What other things are you looking at in
terms of mitigating stress or like what
other factors are there that you have to
keep an eye on?
Yeah,
stress is a bad one.
I try to
take life in my stride,
not get too worried about it.
Remember what's important.
So my heart rate rarely goes up.
Um,
even under a really extreme
circumstances and that that's about it.
I try to balance my life as best I can.
I don't go through airport scanners as
much as I can and have x rays,
these little things.
Do you think those are bad for you?
Those are the new ones.
Aren't there like a radio wave?
Yeah,
they're,
they're millimeter radio waves.
I don't want to take any chances and
also don't want to freak people out.
But the old style ones that were banned
in Europe first,
they were potentially damaging x-rays.
Definitely.
Uh,
try not to have as many as you can,
but flying is just as bad as an x ray.
Well that's the problem that I was going
through a scanner and I said I don't
want to go through the scanner and they
got quite upset because it's a bother,
but they said,
you know,
it's just as much damage to your body as
the flight.
And so I said,
why do I want to double it?
So anyway,
so I go through scan is,
but I try not to.
But let me tell you why I think it's so
bad because scan isn't going to change
what we call the epigenome.
Now,
a lot of people haven't heard of the
epigenome,
the genome,
everybody knows it's your DNA.
Uh,
the code of life,
the epigenome is what regulates and
reads those genes at the right time.
Okay?
And so we've,
we knew about DNA,
we know how to read the genome pretty
easily.
We can do that now on a Mozbar sized
device in a day.
Uh,
the epigenomes quite difficult
different.
The epigenome is that the structure of
how the DNA is looped around.
If you look at the chromosome,
you're not seeing the genome,
you're really basically saying
epigenomes and what w,
what I think is causing aging is not
that you're losing the DNA structure,
you're not having mutations,
you're actually changing the epigenome,
which is the,
the reader of the genes to put another
way,
a compact disc,
okay?
Uh,
for the young audience,
a compact discs are little things we
used to put music on a.
But anyway,
these are,
these are digital information of course.
And the reason we switched to digital in
the first place is that it's very
copyable and it doesn't wear out.
Reza,
a cassette tape,
you know,
people our age know that if you try to
copy that a thousand times,
there's not much left at the end.
So the,
the Compact disc inflammation is the
genome,
the epigenome is the reader of the CD,
that little laser that goes around and
what I think is causing aging is not the
loss of the digital information,
but it's the reader,
the analog part,
and that's like a cassette tape that
eventually runs out.
So what we,
what's going on really is that your
cells are losing the ability to read the
right genes the way they did when you
were 20.
And that's basically noise informational
noise that gathers over time.
Um,
and so what we end up with when we're 80
is a compact disc or DVD that scratched.
So the reader cannot read the right
genes,
that right time in the cells become
dysfunctional.
Now what we're working on is highly that
cd or that DVD to get that information
back again.
And if you can do that,
I think that's really the best way to
reset your age.
And we haven't published it yet,
but uh,
we're working on ways to actually reset
that genome and actually get back the
information that we once had when were
20.
So what is happening to the epigenome
when you're going through those
scanners?
Well,
so what we found is the biggest
disruptor of the epigenome is a,
a broken chromosome,
DNA break,
and I don't know about scanners,
that's just an abundance of caution.
But an x ray will damage your DNA.
No question.
I'm even going out in the sun,
will do a bit of that.
And we think that the cells reaction to
that break having to unwrap the DNA from
its Chromatin,
we call it and uh,
and then rewrap it is what eventually
disrupts the ability to read the right
thing at the right place.
So Dna damage is essentially a little
scratch on,
on the DVD.
And that accumulates over time.
So being out in the sun does that,
but being out in the sun also is
beneficial.
Your body produces more vitamin D.
Yeah.
Well,
so there's also a theory called
antagonistic pleiotropy,
which is what's good for you when you're
young.
Comes back to bite you when you're old,
so you might look good and feel good and
get vitamin D when you're young.
But the accumulation of these scratches
on the epigenome ends up.
You know,
I'm formally in an Australian originally
in Australia now,
American and Australian.
I grew up in this straight and son.
And I can tell you that,
you know,
most Australians look older than they
should know ozone now.
Ozone and lack of sunscreen in the 19
seventies.
Why do you guys have a whole nails on
over Australia?
What's that all about?
What you do?
No,
it's what,
what did the world to chloroform Cognos
to assure a well,
hairspray.
Why does it accumulate over Australia as
a theory?
It started in Antarctica and uh,
so ozone will.
That had been convenient.
Nobody's up there.
Leave it up there.
Yeah.
Well,
if you need to blow it that way.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
that the ozone layer is fairly
important.
Uh,
if you don't want to get singed by UV
light.
Yeah.
Well,
that's one of the first things I noticed
when I went to Australia was a,
there's all these sun cancer warnings,
skin cancer warnings everywhere.
Well,
a third of Australians get some form of
skin cancer,
so that's crazy.
Yeah.
But what's also gonna happen is it'll
disrupt your epic genome over time and
you'll look old,
but if you have an extra,
you're going to damage your organs.
You can accelerate aging,
I believe in your body.
Um,
and it happened.
You can't avoid double strand breaks.
Cra broken chromosomes happens all the
time.
There's trillions of cells in your body
and it's happening all the time.
So living is a problem.
Okay?
Flying,
flying is even worse about what you're
working on is how do you get back that
original information into the cell and
make a sell.
Not just believe that it's 20 again,
but actually be 20.
So what do you do?
We reprogram them.
There are a set of genes that we and
others have found a three main ones that
when you put them into a cell or even
into a mouse,
uh,
they become younger again.
Whoa.
How far do you think you are from
implementing this on human beings as
well?
So theoretically are you doing to
yourself and you could,
you could do it to yourself.
Theoretically I wouldn't do that because
I'm not crazy.
We need to figure out the safety.
I don't want to become a giant tumor
while we'll just use it on bad people.
Uh,
yeah.
Well that take people coming tournament
18 year olds and go,
whoa.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
that,
that would be for someone else.
Someone else.
Well hopefully no one would ever do
that.
Why not?
Well,
what killed him?
His is what we're doing.
I agree with you that we want,
we want to see what happens in humans.
Just give them like free pizza or
something.
They're on death row,
right?
If you're there already murders,
you want to be the first one to me on my
death row,
I don't want to go into death row,
but I'm saying if you're going to kill
somebody,
like wouldn't be a good idea to like,
oh hey,
we'll give you a four hours of tv a day.
So we want to shoot you up with some
stuff's going to make a younger.
If I was on death row and go do it.
See what's up.
I'll watch TV.
Well,
what we do is we give it all nice and we
check it.
What happens to their body.
So nursing home people to it,
to them.
Right.
Well tell you what,
I wouldn't force anyone,
but if somebody was blind or almost
blind and now studies were recovering
eyesight.
Really?
What about the damage to us?
Yeah.
Really?
Uh,
so I don't want to freak out because I
know a guy who's got significantly
damaged,
die from fighting.
Well,
I can tell you what we've done,
and this is work with writing up for
publication now.
We've done a few things.
Three things to the mice.
One is waived,
pinched their optic nerve and crushed
it,
which is a test for growing new neurons
in the eye.
And we find that without reprogramming,
we can make the nerves be just like a
newborn baby.
They grow back.
And then we also tested on glaucoma
pressure in the eye.
We increased pressure in the mouse as I.
and they lose their largely their
eyesight and we can recover that.
And then we also test old mice that
don't see very well and we also seem to
improve their eyesight almost back to
normal.
So what,
I don't think we'll be going into
nursing homes anytime soon,
but what we are doing is running a
clinical trial on this.
Um,
and so we're looking to do that in early
20 slash 20 and the clinical trial will
be on people with glaucoma or various
eye issues.
The plan is glaucoma first,
but it could work for other damage
written as well.
Even broken spinal cords where we're
thinking of trying.
Wow.
And that's just one part of the body.
Imagine what it could potentially do to
the rest of them.
Do you feel incredibly fortunate to be
living in the century?
Uh,
I do every day,
but I would love to live next century
because it's going to be.
Yeah.
But you're,
what's cool is you're kind of at the,
the tip of the spear pushing this stuff
right now.
Like you're going to be one of the guys
that gets to see this stuff get
implemented from your actual own
research where it didn't exist before.
Uh,
yeah,
that's pretty damn cool.
Better than like living 100 years from
now where you just take it for granted.
Like a trust fund kid,
you know?
But just imagine what you can do in 100
years.
You can.
Well maybe you'll be here.
Were on the.
Yeah,
you might be 150.
We'll see.
I think there's a chance someone will
be.
Well,
it's,
it's a good chance you're going to be.
I mean you're the one who's going to
know.
Well.
So here's my philosophy.
I'm not gonna.
Let anyone try technology until I've
tried it first.
Really?
Is this a pause because you're,
you're currently doing something like
that.
I'm not doing the three programming yet.
That's a little dangerous.
But the others I've always wanted to
know first.
My eyesight is starting to go because
I'm 51 now and like when I had to read
this book,
I got a Nick Christakis book from
sitting here reading this book.
If I don't have reading glasses on,
I got to do this.
It's a bit of a struggle to be able to
fix that.
So potentially in the mice we can,
you can,
we will.
We don't give them books to read,
but their eyesight improves.
We can test that.
How do you do it?
Uh,
there's a moving screen.
No,
I don't,
I don't mean how do you,
how do you know,
how do you test or not?
How you tests rather.
How do you improve their eyesight?
Uh,
we've,
we put these reprogramming genes into a
virus which has already used to treat
genetic diseases in the eye and we
inject it straight into the master's
level.
This sounds like the beginning of a
horror movie.
Yeah.
I think it's actually an awesome movie.
It's the awesome part that I'm focused
on.
Well,
if you're going blind,
right?
One injection from your doctor and then
you take an antibiotic,
turn the genes on for as long as you
need and you get your eyesight back.
That's not horrific at all.
That's a pretty incredible.
How far away do you think you are of
doing that to humans?
Well,
20,
20 will be the first safety study we.
Wow.
Yeah,
but the,
the crazy stuff,
the future is if this all goes well,
you have an injection in your vein,
let's say when you're 30 and in those
viruses infect your body and they sit
there dormant until you need them,
so when might you need them?
You might have a car accident turned
them on,
can turn them on with just a,
an antibiotic in a drip or a pill,
or you start to lose your eyesight,
take it,
take an antibiotic.
So you put them in your body almost as
an insurance policy and then you have
the option to turn them on in the
future.
Exactly.
Wow.
That's what we do in the mice.
Now with every action,
we assume there's some negative
consequence or potentially negative
consequence.
Right?
We always assume that,
but it's not always right.
So with the molecules that we've been
testing for years now,
like can a man,
we haven't seen any downside,
just longer endurance and protection.
So there isn't always a downside to
these things.
In fact,
if you just think nmn is replacing a
molecule that we lose over time as we
get older,
it's just becoming,
you know,
it's fairly natural process.
No downside exercising and dieting
either.
Right.
Of course.
And you said you run once a week.
Is that what you,
you and you do,
do you lift weights as well?
Right.
And when you do it,
do try to not go too hard or burn
yourself out too much?
Uh,
do you have a sweet spot?
Yeah.
Um,
I do,
I try not to go too much.
I that that's the trick with everything
in life.
It's this,
uh,
hormesis effect.
Get your body damaged enough that it can
repair itself,
but give you the benefits without like
having a lot of x rays or radiation.
We're doing it and scratching that CD.
Yeah.
My,
that's always my thought on people that
do extreme endurance activities like
ultra marathons and things along those
lines.
Um,
I mean I marvel at their willpower and
their ability to push themselves through
that and the physical condition they
have to be in to perform such feats.
But I always think,
man,
you're probably doing x times the amount
of damage to your body that a normal
person does at your age.
It sounds right.
Calorie restriction works,
but if you overdo it,
you also starve you.
Yeah.
You Die.
So you gotta find the right balance,
right?
Yeah.
How do you,
how do you know what the right balance
is for you?
Good question.
How does anybody,
um,
so we live in an age that is still
fairly primitive.
This is why I liked the future.
Um,
these days we go to the doctor or most
of us go to the doctor for annual
physical,
which is ludicrous.
The idea that your doctor will take
hopefully a blood test,
a prostate exam once a year.
That's kind of crazy.
What happens if you've got a tumor that
developed the day,
you leave the doctor's office.
So the future,
and actually partially for those who are
on the cutting edge can be done right
now.
It's monitoring your body in various
ways genetically,
epigenetically.
We can measure those scratches right
now.
And also with blood tests,
you can also have companies tell you if
you're out of range,
if you're not optimized and how to get
it back in order.
So that's what I do.
So how often do you monitor your blood?
Uh,
probably every few months.
I have a blood test from a company that
tells me what I need to correct and how
extensive it is.
Is this blood test like because it the
standard one that a normal person can
get or do you have to have a
prescription to get this or.
Oh No,
you can go online and get it.
Uh,
it's uh,
about I think 40 parameters they measure
some that are not standard that you're
Dr wouldn't do.
Some are pretty standard.
Um,
but what's nice is it's,
it's a tracking system.
It's called inside tracker and they,
you can see over time if things are
going up and even if they're not out of
range yet,
you can see if they headed that
direction and correct it before it's too
late.
So that's why one of the reasons I'm on
Metformin,
my blood glucose was going up and up and
up,
which predicts lower life and some
metformin got it back down to where it
was optimal again.
So that's one of the things that
metformin does,
is it lowers your blood glucose.
That's what it's prescribed for,
for diabetics.
Now,
does that have any effect on your energy
levels?
Uh,
I don't think so.
I haven't noticed that.
Where you would notice it is during
rigorous exercise.
That makes sense.
Do you feel it?
Uh,
well,
so I take metformin at night.
Um,
so that may be probably the best thing.
Right?
So when you're sleeping it's having its
effect and it's run its course by the
time you wake up,
you believe?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Um,
now when you are exercising,
are you exercising fasted or do you take
certain amount of carbohydrates for you?
Do any kind of physical exercise?
Uh,
so I started the gym,
uh,
two,
2:00 PM on a Sunday and I'll have a
salad rapper or something like that.
So I'm not feeling hungry during it and
one pass out.
Huh?
And um,
so I understand that you're getting
these blood tests,
but do you have a trainer?
Do you,
do you set a workout or you structure
it?
I do now.
Just recently got a trainer.
Um,
it's great thing to do with your son,
father,
son time.
So yeah,
that we have an hour of trainer and then
we,
we also do a bit of boxing.
Um,
and you're beating yourself up.
Yeah,
it's fun.
It's legal.
I think go to the sauna and then there's
just the best way to spend a day.
That is a nice way to spend a day.
So I'm a you,
how many days a week you're doing this
or do you give yourself days off?
Do you,
you schedule that?
Well,
so once a day of that are once a week on
a Sunday and during the week if I have a
chance and I'm not traveling,
I go to the home gym.
And when you say you run once a week,
is that by design that you only give
yourself once a week?
I'd probably run two times a week.
A high intensity,
um,
if I could.
And I try to do that often I'm on a
plane or right,
and we say high intensity or you
sprinting doing track work.
Like what kind of stuff?
Yeah,
so I'm not an expert,
so what I do is I.
I will spend or have spent a half an
hour on one of those treadmills that's u
shaped.
Yeah,
I got one of those out of here.
Yeah.
Great.
They are so that you determine your
speed.
So I'll,
I'll sprint and then I'll slow down and
sprint slow down.
There are actually more difficult than
running on a flat surface where a
regular treadmills is actually easier
than running because the treadmills
moving and you just kind of lifting your
legs up and keeping moving.
With this actually you're powering it.
So by you pushing on it,
it's actually more.
It's like running.
I forget what the degree incline is,
but it's like an x,
x amount percentage harder than a
regular run.
Oh good.
Well that's what feels good to me.
And although it's a little bit scary if
you're not used to these treadmills,
you can run off the front because they
are free flowing.
Go right off the tip.
They have handles.
Oh yeah,
you're a genius.
You're not going to go flying off the
treadmill like a dummy.
I'm no genius.
Especially when it comes to sport.
Well,
yeah,
the album,
I'm a big fan of those things and it's
nice too because there's a lot of give
to them.
There's not much pounding when you run
on those.
It's not like running on hard surfaces.
So I try to go easy on my joints.
I've seen you've probably all seen
sports players with all sorts of damage
that joints and I've done all of it.
Yeah.
So yeah,
low impact,
high intensity and it as far as weight
lifting,
we will kind of stuff you do in there
because weightlifting does have a
beneficial effect on bone density and
it's supposedly has an effect on anti
aging as well.
Uh,
yeah,
absolutely believe in that until I try
to maintain some muscle mass.
It's good for burning fat too.
So,
you know,
I tried to do a not go overboard with
the bench presses and otherwise I'll
have even more well rounded shoulders
trying to get the straight back.
So the trainer is helping me bring my
body back into shape.
He took one look at me and he said,
you,
you did this unsupervised direct your
body in your twenties.
Let's try to fix that.
What did he say you were doing wrong?
Uh,
I said,
well,
why would you do an exercise and a part
of your body you can't see in the
mirror?
Oh,
your back.
My back is flimsy and it's all here.
So I stand like,
you're a smart man.
It's protecting your spine.
I love benchpressing.
Oh God.
Please don't use
your shoulders out too though,
right?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Especially if you do it heavy.
Now I'm you do this.
How many days a week?
Hopefully two or three.
Two or three a week.
So all the,
everything you're doing you would
essentially recommend to others as well.
Right?
So you think that's a good plan?
Two to three days a week of
weightlifting.
One to two days.
A week of running sauna when you can.
So I never used the word recommend gets
me into trouble.
Yeah,
good move.
I just say what I do and people can
judge but as smart,
but the science does say this is the
optimal and that's why I've chosen it
for myself,
but I think without monitoring yourself
easy to overdo it and also you just
really don't know what's going on in the
inside.
It's crazy to think we know more about
our cars as we drive on the dashboard
then we do about our bodies.
How does anybody know if the exercises
too much,
too little or if that supplements doing
anything right with that is a big
problem.
Right?
I mean one of the things that we have a
giant problem in mma is tainted
supplements.
People buying supplements.
The supplements have other things in
them.
And
what are you drinking?
Do you drink mostly water to consume
caffeine?
Uh,
so with Nmn,
which gives me a boost,
I think caffeine is a little too
intense,
so I find that.
So I'll have a cup of coffee in the
morning,
but that's it one a day.
Yeah.
Wow.
Just to kick it to live,
it's hard.
It's really hard,
right?
When you're doing research all the time,
don't you need a little boost sometimes?
Well,
I,
I do drink a diet coke or how dare you
just ruined everything.
You said you're doing that?
Yeah.
It's my fucking horrible for you.
Is it that bad?
Aspartame?
Well,
I actually had an inflated idea of how
bad it was apparently talking to another
research scientist,
uh,
he was telling me that the actual amount
that they gave to rats when they're
diagnosing them with cancer is almost
impossible for a person to consume.
So you'd have to have ungodly amounts of
aspartame in order to get these effects
that everyone's terrified of.
You said the other thing to take into
consideration is look around at how many
people are drinking diet coke?
He goes,
it was really that bad.
They'd be dropping like flies.
The consideration though is upsetting
your gut biome,
right?
That I know,
or at least I've read,
but he said that's also probably large
quantities.
Uh,
it's true.
but,
uh,
as you know,
the microbiome is a finicky thing and
you don't want to mess with that.
The reason I have this,
this yoga in the morning,
trying to reset the thing.
D,
Kim all.
Uh,
yeah.
Not regularly,
but yeah,
that's,
that's
what about other fermented vegetables or
anything along those lines.
The probiotic
Japanese food into.
But I don't think about my diet that
often.
Usually too busy running around.
But
now have you ever messed around with
nootropics or anything like that to
enhance your mental clarity or boost
your brain power?
W?
Well,
yeah.
My,
my brain is always running a marathon.
Right?
That's my career.
I definitely noticed that if I take time
off even a weekend without thinking I'm
dumber on Monday,
dumber.
Well yeah,
I just can't really.
So like it's almost like you need to
keep that pace going for sure.
Oh,
right,
right.
I guess I'm not a natural genius.
I have to work at it,
but I do find that that constant
stimulation,
I've got to do that to be at the peak.
And this is the APP.
This is the genetics department at
Harvard medical school and these are no
dummies.
These,
a quarter of them,
a Nobel prize winners.
And you got to.
I'm going to load the science,
we published the world's top journals,
which you really get into,
so to be able to think of these ideas
and come up with new things,
you can't just do that on a,
on a whim.
You really have to have a mind that is
focused and in shape.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So it is essentially you feel like
running,
like you would take days off.
He actually slipped back a little bit
and then you have to ramp back up to
speed.
It's horrible.
I really hate it.
But is it just because you just get used
to a lazy pace and you have to like
acclimate to get back in the lab or is
it actually you do get dumber?
Um,
I don't have the memory recall.
Uh,
I,
I feel like I did when I was in my
twenties,
which is I wasn't as sharp.
I'm a lot sharper than I was then.
So part of it could be the mental
training that I give myself every,
every day.
The other part could be that the
molecules that I'm taking,
so nmn raising nad could have neurotoxic
effects.
We don't know.
Yeah,
I'm sure I'm creatine supposedly has
nootropic effects as well.
Do you ever take that?
No.
Caffeine certainly does.
I'd like to get you some actual
nootropics.
I'll send you some.
There's a bunch of different ones that I
use.
I use three different companies.
One that's one of mine and uh,
to the other companies,
neuro one and another one called true
brain and I find them pretty beneficial.
Right?
I could do with that.
Yeah,
it,
it'll definitely.
Well,
the one that we've tested was Alpha
brain.
We tested the Boston Center for memory.
They did a double blind.
Placebo controlled study showed increase
in verbal memory,
increased reaction,
speed,
reaction time.
Um,
but the,
the other ones,
Prasad,
to them of your mess with any of those,
know Coleen,
your supplement with that.
No.
Interesting.
Right?
I could be smarter I guess.
Well,
this,
I don't think it's that.
It's just,
it's not smarter.
It's,
I don't think anything makes you
smarter.
I think knowledge makes you smarter.
What it does is gives you access,
I think,
to something that's already in your
head.
Good,
little bit,
little smoother.
Good recall is important.
The other thing as a scientist,
what you need is you need to see a
thousand different sets of data and put
them into one.
They can see the connections.
So I'm exposed to so much information.
It's drinking from a fire hose every
day.
I'm reading papers,
I'm talking to dozens of people,
have got dozens of companies,
got two labs in the world.
It's just coming in and for my brain to
take it in,
sorted out,
finds links between them,
connect that person with that
politician,
with that person in the military.
It's all going on.
And a regular brain that isn't trained
would have a hard time.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
I'm so shocked the only drink one cup of
coffee a day with that kind of schedule.
Uh,
well.
So the sentiment is good.
Um,
do you take nad in an Ivy for?
No,
no,
I've,
I haven't,
but I've talked to many people that have
been scheduling it or wanting to
schedule it and putting it off for
weeks.
But uh,
I'm going to do that soon because I just
know too many people that have extreme
benefits from it.
Yeah,
sounds good.
Um,
do you know anyone who has done it?
No,
that seems like something will be right
up your alley.
A.
Yeah,
you'd think just being more focused on
curing aging,
but nad does have supposedly some sort
of an effect on aging.
Correct.
Ivy Nad I don't know about an ivy nad
it's been poorly studied,
actually has a lot of anecdotes and I
hear about these all the time but I
haven't seen really a hardcore double
blind placebo
controlled trials now.
And add in supplemental form though in
terms of oral orally ingested any day a
well.
So if you give an a to an animal or a
cell,
it taken up really poorly.
Nad is a big molecule.
NMN is a smaller version of ned that
gets into cells quickly.
So that's probably a difference.
Ah.
So it's the same benefit but it's easier
consumed orally?
Well I think so.
I mean it was still at the cutting edge
of figuring out what's true and what
isn't.
But Nad is thought to not be well
absorbed in the body as compared to
these other smaller molecules that the
body then turns into nad once it gets
in,
how much water do you drink?
Not Enough.
I was just speaking with um,
some members of Tom Come Brady's team
and they said,
David,
you got to drink more.
Tom Brady's team.
I,
yeah.
You mean is like physical team,
like the Patriots now,
uh,
his,
his CEO of his company.
Oh,
okay.
And they're saying you need to drink
more and you went and got to see.
It's like a suggestion.
I'm drinking,
I'm drinking a lot more.
All right.
Then you end up just going to the
bathroom off the time,
but,
uh,
got to do what you gotta do you do,
you do.
It makes sense to me having a buildup of
toxins in your body and urea isn't a
good thing.
Right?
Um,
do you take anything else that,
uh,
is notable?
Well,
I can run you through it.
I'm on Lippert note a Staton for.
I've been on staten since I was in my
twenties.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
that stuff's fucking terrible for you.
right.
So my good friend and colleague George
Church at Harvard told me I'm killing
myself,
but I have really high cholesterol.
My family genetically.
Genetically.
Yeah.
And um,
does your family have a history of heart
disease because of this?
Yeah.
So my grandmother,
um,
at least according to her had a stroke
in her thirties and then yeah,
it's bad.
So I'm fighting bad Ashkenazi Jew jeans
here.
That's crazy.
He'd been on them since you're in your
twenties,
that's in your thin man.
If anybody looked at you,
they would never think that you would
have an issue.
Yeah,
it's unfortunate,
but I'm,
I'm a doctor's worst nightmare first of
all,
I teach them so I know what they're
like.
Uh,
but also when I go into the doctor's
office I say,
here's what we should be doing.
Well you should be doing to me.
And I saw,
I went in my twenties and I said,
I want to go into status and this is in
the days when statens weren't well
studied and my doctor said,
but you're not old.
And I said,
I don't want to wait until I'm old and
sick to get this medicine.
I need it now.
And I fought the doctor foot,
the doctor,
and eventually he prescribed it and my
cholesterol came down.
Uh,
I'm the same with dentists.
I went to the dentist a few months ago
and I said,
I want my teeth fixed,
my two front teeth.
And she said they find normal wear and
tear.
And I said,
okay,
what's normal?
Fixed my teeth.
Get them back to how I was when I was
20.
No,
we don't do that.
We don't do that.
Well,
you did my daughter right last week.
Yeah.
But she's young.
She's got a future.
Like,
oh see done.
Don't be wrong with your teeth are
wearing out.
And I hated feeling that one out.
I'm wearing cow.
You don't get that way.
Uh,
just getting shorter and flatter and
what the fuck you eat and rocks.
I must be the Australian Diet.
A lot of sand in your food.
So I said to her,
I thought you were one of the world's
best dentist.
And she said,
okay,
fine,
I'll do it.
But don't blame me if it doesn't work.
Um,
and so she works like,
well,
she was worried that it might snap off
or putting a cap on you.
Yeah,
she's extending my two front teeth were
just normal,
like people get caps all the time.
I.
Well it's not a cap.
It's actually just material stuck to the
tape just on the tip.
It's also like if you had a chip too,
they would do that instead of replace
the actual.
That's what I did to my daughter and I
said,
do that to me.
That looks great.
And she said,
no,
no.
Finally she said,
okay,
but it's your problem.
You got to pay for it.
Fine.
Uh,
and she did it and she actually said at
the end of it,
this is great.
I might offer this as a procedure to
other patients,
but.
But my point is not about teeth,
it's the medical profession is ageist.
They give young people certain
treatments because they're young and
they don't give them to the old,
but then they don't give the young
people the treatments that they need
before they get old.
Wacky.
I had a similar thing happened with a
torn meniscus,
a minor meniscus tear,
and the guy told me,
well if you were young,
they would stitch it up and hope that it
would heal.
I'm like,
what the fuck does that mean?
I go,
everything works good.
Like what is different?
What is the difference between me and a
younger body of.
And he said something about blood flow,
you have more blood flow.
And I said,
look,
I'm not a doctor but that doesn't make
any sense.
I go,
I'm working out all the time.
There's a lot of blood going through
there,
like what the fuck is happening?
And I'm like let's just shoot some stem
cells in there and see what's up because
they wanted to do a meniscus.
The
meniscus copy,
whatever they call it when they cut some
of the meniscus out and I'm like,
Eh,
let's just,
let's just try it.
It's totally working like A.
I don't have any pain in it now.
So I think there's a weird thing that
they do do when you get to a certain
age,
like Eh,
like I have a friend who was a torn acl
and they essentially,
he's in his fifties,
late fifties,
and they essentially told not to fix it.
I go,
Hey fucker,
get it fixed.
What are you crazy?
And I have a wobbly knee.
And they're like,
well,
they told me if I was younger,
did I fuck that doctor?
Go get that thing fixed.
He's like,
well how the recovery time?
Like shut up,
you just recover.
You're alive.
A year goes by,
it's fixed.
Just stop.
Just go get it fixed.
Yeah.
See that's the problem with today's
society because we think a 50 old is
dale that's dead at 50 is still very
young.
Actually there are 78,
70 year old 80 year olds,
nine year olds still playing tennis,
loving life.
That's,
that's just the beginning of what's
coming.
If you maintain activity that that seems
to be the key.
The the really hard thing is when
someone's in their fifties and they want
to get in shape now and they haven't
been active their whole life,
that seems to be a problem.
Their DVD is scratched up.
Yes.
Hard to go back.
It can be done though.
I did see a guy who was 58 years old who
started running marathons at 58 in his
seventies.
He's running a sub three hour marathons
and he looks great,
so it just.
He just had to take his time and really
be dedicated and watch his diet,
nutrition and next thing you know,
this guy's an elite marathon runner.
It is doable.
What we find in the lab is if we treat
mice early in life,
it gives them the battle much better
life.
Spanish,
sure.
So don't ever leave it too late.
Will you see that with athletes like
athletes that were fit when they were
young and never lost it,
really maintained and stayed in the gym
and stayed active.
You see them in their fifties and
sixties looking great.
Whereas you know,
it's just once your body deteriorates,
it's very difficult to bring it back.
But if you maintain it,
it seems like there's people today that
are doing that.
It's much more common if you go to a
gym,
for instance,
go to a nice gym,
you'll see a lot of folks that are in
their sixties and seventies that are
really active and they're there all the
time and they're regulars had the gym
and they look great.
They do.
So my father is a,
as a prime example of that.
So he's in Australia and he's been
taking care of his body since he was in
his early forties.
Probably a little too late,
but still he's been taking metformin for
awhile.
Resveratrol.
But he's been active.
That's the key,
I think.
And then,
uh,
so that combination.
So he's now just turning 80 this year.
You would think that he's 30 if you,
if you didn't know his age and he's
running around.
My mother passed away from cancer.
So he's,
he's dating women.
He's out every night.
He's traveling the world now.
This is the future for,
for people in their eighties.
Um,
he started a new career at 80.
It was at a 76.
What's he doing?
He got bored,
so he retired at 67,
thought he hadn't now the 10 years of
goodlife and he kept going and going,
going.
His friends are getting frail.
He's still active,
so he went back and he's working at
Sydney University on the ethics panel
for clinical trials and other studies
and that's what you want older people
with wisdom and knowledge to do,
to give back.
That sounds good too.
Like for you,
you get your dad hopped up on all these
awesome new drugs.
Then you get them working on the ethics
panel for clinical studies and then you
get them to give you some death row
patients so you can try it on.
Right.
Ethics,
you're onto me.
Yes,
I know what you're doing now man.
You're wiggling the system a little bit
with your.
Keep it in the family.
Hyper active,
super healthy dad.
Right?
Well,
I don't recommend anything even to my
family,
but they end up to mending it.
My brother was pretty upset that we
weren't giving him any.
Well,
it seems like it's working out really
well for your father.
I mean,
so metformin,
the Nmm and what else is he taking a,
he's also on a Staton and he exercises.
That's amazing.
So he's understanding as well because he
has the same predisposed condition,
right?
That's an awful condition,
man.
That,
that may mean.
One of the things that I was talking to
my doctor about it,
he was saying that that there are people
that just have high blood pressure or
higher,
you know,
higher blood pressure,
higher instances of heart disease and
their family and it's just a really
unfortunate genetic issue.
Uh,
it is,
it is.
But fortunately we were able to tackle
heart disease pretty well these days
with blood pressure,
drugs,
cholesterol,
drugs.
There were some side effects,
no question.
But what we're talking about with these
longevity drugs that are in development
is that sure you can be prescribed this
medicine for your Alzheimer's or fewer
liver disease,
but as a side effect,
it'll keep the rest of your body healthy
as well.
Protect you against cancer and all these
other things.
That's what's so radical,
what we're doing
now.
Um,
what about crispr and what do you think
a is going to come out of that in terms
of like real world application for an
adult?
I mean,
what if people don't know what Crispr
is?
Please explain it in layman's terms.
Uh,
yeah,
so crispr is a term that was invented in
my department probably,
so I know it pretty well.
It's a back bacteria,
have an immune system that cuts
invaders,
cut the DNA and what we've done now as
scientists,
we've now utilize that system,
take it out of the bacteria and we use
it to create designer mutations,
design a gene,
changes in animals and also in humans.
So it's a bacterial immune system that
corrects genes and we use it all the
time now.
It's um,
it's,
it's actually what's interesting about
is being able to mutate genes for many
years,
but this is dial up a gene mutation.
You can choose exactly where you want to
make it.
And uh,
so I think many of your listeners will
know that recently,
a late last year,
Chinese researcher and our field came
out and said he's engineered a couple of
twin girls with crispr to be resistant
to HIV AIDS virus.
Wow.
Um,
if they're telling you that when you got
to think they're doing some stuff
they're not telling you about,
right?
Well,
yeah.
Have some kids with giant heads and.
Well it's coming through walls.
Rewind.
Well yeah,
if you start to see people that are 90
and they're still as young as 20,
you know,
something's going on.
Yeah.
That's the weird
one,
right?
If you can,
you'd go,
Hey,
what are you doing?
Nothing.
Just eating
healthy looking good.
Take care of bots.
Not going to tell you.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
so consider this,
that.
So the chance of getting HIV in China is
one in a thousand.
So that doctor was seemingly,
he thought he was ethical,
protecting the babies from something
that's,
I would say really rare.
Whereas if you really wanted to do
something helpful to those kids and we
agreed it was something you should do,
why not make them resistant to heart
disease or cancer?
We can do that.
It was weird that he chose HIV as the
first test.
Why do you think they did that?
Um,
I think because it was a very well
understood mutation that would,
if you just destroyed the gene,
it would work.
Whereas with these other diseases,
you have to be much more precise.
But the reason that we scientists got
really upset was that he did it in
secrecy and then just launched it on the
world and that kind of thing because
it's a fine line in ethics.
You want to be doing that with total
transparency running.
I think he was hoping to become a win a
Nobel prize or be a star and it,
it backfired on him because he,
he just did it in secrecy.
It backfired in the scientific
community.
Absolutely.
In the real world,
in the media,
I was shocked how little discussion
there was.
If this news came out in the two
thousands during the Bush era,
it would,
there would have been panels,
investigations,
it would have been in the news for
months,
but it wasn't.
People went,
Ahhh.
What's next on twitter?
Do you think?
It's just because of the news cycle.
So insane.
I do.
Yeah.
Um,
when you have a scientific experiment of
that nature,
what's the standard protocol for a
scientist?
Whether it is or is it the same in China
and in Russia and the United States as a
scientific community almost operate
under different,
like a different set of rules than
anything else.
You mean between countries or.
I mean,
you know,
like obviously technology is not shared
like China is doing something
technologically.
United States is,
we have to speculate,
we have to figure it out.
But when it comes to medical science,
right,
is it sort of an open book because
everybody sharing information a no,
or at least alerting everyone to what
they're working on or.
Well,
I know where you're going with this.
At least I think I do.
Uh,
yeah.
So I advised governments around the
world about what's going on.
I'm under the radar as best I know and
there are countries I'm not going to
name them that are doing research under
the radar and are preventing people like
myself from entering those buildings to
have a look what's going on.
Yeah.
So I'm sure that,
um,
what's going on in there is actually a
little bit broader than what we hear
about,
but I don't know.
How long has it performed?
Just say Russia.
No,
I didn't say Russia.
I didn't say anything.
No country.
I want to be able to travel to Russia.
Bye.
Oh,
I said
it.
But in,
in,
in countries where there are a stent,
different standards.
What's stopping a mothers who wants to
prevent their child from having heart
disease which could kill their child,
you know,
40 percent chance versus 100,000 and
eventually you could make a child that
could live 200 years once we know how to
do it.
That could be the future.
There's always a concern that someone is
doing something that is beneficial in
one way but negative in another way.
And if everyone doesn't get to examine
the research,
um,
it's very difficult.
Like if we wanted to in the United
States wanted to do something similar to
what they're doing over there,
we would want to have access to what
they've learned,
right?
Uh,
we would.
And so generally scientists share
inflammation,
but there are companies that are
government owned that are very sacred,
right?
Or even private organizations and that's
where it's a little tricky and that's
why we,
we signed his get really upset when
companies or organizations don't share
information,
especially in something this critical
and what's not really stated,
but it's my belief is that one of the
reasons it was such a backlash against
this crispr design,
a baby experiment and it really was an
experiment and it's not just that it was
potentially dangerous and you could end
up with kids that have deformities,
but also that unless we do this in a,
in a measured manner,
under supervision,
there's,
there could be a backlash like there was
against stem cell research in the two
thousands.
We don't want that.
Again,
we want to be able to do this the right
way this time.
Right?
Is it particularly if something goes
wrong with those children?
One person could ruin it for millions of
people.
Jump The gun and yeah,
so we're,
we're on the second generation of
Crispr.
Is that correct?
Use of the editing tools.
They've become more.
They have that.
There's,
there's surprisingly that there's lot of
different bacteria that have the,
these systems,
so we're,
we're getting new ones all the time.
Some that are more accurate because you
don't want what we call off target
effect.
You don't want to accidentally mutates
some Jane that's required for head
development.
Um,
and so yeah,
we're,
I think in my department were on fourth
generation,
fourth generation.
Wow.
Yeah.
See I'm just going by radio lab
podcasts.
Yeah.
So My,
my department have fun,
Fun Department to be.
Imagine they are imitating all sorts of
stuff.
What did you ever see the documentary
icarus?
Oh yeah,
it rings a bell.
It's Brian Fogle's documentary on the
Russian doping program,
state sponsored doping program in Sochi,
the Sochi Olympics and how they had this
incredibly complicated system of
stealing the urine and putting it
through a hole in the wall and putting
fake urine back through.
It was really,
really amazing.
Amazing,
amazing documentary,
but details
this incredibly complicated state
sponsored doping system.
I would imagine that with something like
crispr or some various new forms of
genetic editing that that's one of the
things that they're going to be looking
into,
that they're going to be looking into
things that are gonna,
enhance athletic performance.
Yeah.
I mean you might need to have a DNA test
to see if you've put one of these
viruses in your.
Why you 50 and now you're running like a
20 year old,
so that's all possible.
You know that the.
I also write reports for governments and
one of the things that I predicted 50
within the next 15 years was crispr
being used to engineer the human genome
and make a baby.
I didn't realize it was going to happen
within one year.
Wow.
A lot of these technologies that I'm
trying to predict happened way faster
than even I think.
Is gonna happen.
Do you think it's possibly happened in
other circumstances that they're not
going public with
it?
It's always possible.
That may be some human clones running
around right now that we don't know
about.
Do you think so it's certainly doable.
Scientifically,
there might be some rogue nation who's
doing it.
Barbara streisand's togs,
or were pretty easy to clone.
Yeah.
That she had her dogs cloned,
right?
Yeah.
Sammy,
the 14 year old dog is now,
uh,
there's two of them.
Jesus Christ.
It is so weird.
That'd be like,
as I'd be so scared,
I'd go to sleep and wake up.
That thing will be hovering over my face
was red glowing eyes.
Yeah.
Wait till you have designed a cemetery.
What?
A friend of mine,
Carlos Bustamante at Stanford,
we were entertaining the idea of making
dogs live longer,
uh,
genetically.
So why would you want your family member
to only live 12 years?
I think about that man.
My daughter's only two and he's such a
sweetie,
you know,
I'm sad that one day.
I mean I had to put my dog down recently
and who's 13?
And it was really a massive two and he
was struggling and I just think man,
this two year old one day he's going to
be in that same sort of situation.
Well it isn't.
And so we have three dogs.
My wife runs a therapy dog.
Streisand had her beloved dog.
Samantha cloned that crazy bitch.
Look at her two copies of one dog.
Jesus Christ.
That's so strange.
How much just get a new dog.
You fucking nuts.
Well,
so
we might be nuts in my household because
we were giving out dogs and a man.
Oh,
and how's it?
Dylan?
How old's the dog?
The oldest dog is nine and he's still
doing fine.
How does he look different?
My wife says so these are anecdotes.
I'm not gonna publish them,
but I'm so alice has a therapy dog and
he has to go to hospitals and nursing
homes and if he has nmn according to my
wife,
he can't be a therapy dog because he's
too excited.
He's running around,
jumping around really?
So that,
that's anecdotal,
but that seems to fit with what others
have experienced too.
Wow.
Yeah.
So what we're hoping to have some
treatments for some pets are shortly.
One of the companies that I'm working
with treatments for pets.
Yeah.
Well you got to think,
hey man,
dogs only live 13 years anyway,
you know.
Well yeah.
And also we have a dog that has a kidney
defect and the vet says it's only going
to live five years,
so she's three now.
So that's the one you experiment on what
we experiment on on,
on all of them.
But.
But what's the downside that's got to be
so uncomfortable for some people
listening to this right now.
Like,
oh,
I don't know how to feel about that.
Right.
What is the downside?
If your dog has got a kidney defect and
it's only going to probably live to be
nine,
meanwhile the dog's going to live to be
a thousand years old.
Well,
we'll say I'll come back.
I'll let you know in the Lotus position,
meditating 100 years from now.
What do you do?
If it starts talking to you,
that'd be great.
Yeah.
What?
What do you do if you turn a dog into
some new kind of thing that lives 30 or
40 years,
what do you tell people?
Like if your dog,
like right now you're talking about on
the podcast and for a bunch of people
probably going to remember,
but a lot of people for yet.
But if like 15,
20 years from now,
your dog's still chasing balls and
people are going to come over your
house.
Hey Dave,
what the fuck's going on with your dog,
man?
Right.
Same Dog.
That's Charlie.
Yeah.
How come Charlie doesn't have gray hair
anymore,
man.
Right.
Well,
you know,
people ask have any gray hair?
No.
Yeah,
man,
that's weird,
isn't it?
You don't have any.
That's what you're driving.
How long have you been on this stuff?
A wild rose virtual.
I started 12 years ago.
It form in about three years ago.
And a man about the same time.
Wow.
Does anyone in your family have gray
hair?
Is it a genetic issue?
Um,
my father has old gray hair.
My brothers about the query to have
grade.
Wow.
Is your brother taking the stuff you're
taking?
Only recently.
Ah,
interesting.
Yeah,
we call that an n of three in an
experiment,
which is insufficient.
Right?
So I don't want to get slapped on the
wrist by a,
of course with medical schools,
somebody who's saying all these things,
you're just answering questions.
Sorry.
Do not worry.
Right?
But so far so good.
If I'm around in another hundred years,
we'll know something.
So that would be unbelievably
fascinating.
If your dog lived to be like 30 or 40
years old,
that would be really incredible.
And if I meet you in 15 years,
you still have dark hair.
I'll be like,
what?
What the hell,
man,
what are the things are you taking?
Do you take multivitamins?
I take vitamin D,
that's it with Katie.
Just Vitamin D.
Yeah.
What about e or k or any of those?
K Two and d together.
And that's it.
Oh Hm.
So I'm,
I'm afraid of iron.
Afraid of it.
Yeah.
Why?
Uh,
there's some results that I've seen
that,
that excess iron,
especially in the elderly leads to
Senescence of cells and buildup of those
Zombie cells is a bad thing.
And is this a dietary iron from
vegetables or is it from cooking on a
cast iron pan or.
Well,
I only know from correlation.
So I'm,
I'm looking at tissue that's full of
iron and the cells are not looking good.
So all I can think is I don't want to
overload myself on it.
So this is,
I'm like,
hmm.
How much iron is too much iron?
We don't know yet because I always hear
it,
especially from women.
Iron deficiencies for some reason.
I,
I hear,
I've heard it from several women.
Uh,
sure.
but for the elderly,
overloading them with Ian I think is a
real problem.
So there's a sweet spot to hit.
Well,
yeah,
I'm sure.
I'm sure there is.
But uh,
the iron will will damage your cells
pretty badly,
so you don't want to go overboard and no
other supplements.
Now I try to eat vegetables which
hopefully will make sure I'm,
I'm not deficient in anything.
Green leafy dark vegetables.
Exactly,
exactly.
If I can call her straight out of the
fridge instead of going for the,
for uh,
the,
uh,
piece of cooked meat,
I'll go for a carrot or something.
Eight somebody carrots,
I'll probably turn orange now.
Carrots have a little sugar,
a great.
Now I've got to cut out my carrots.
Well,
I mean,
especially if you drink them in the
juice form,
like I know a lot of friends who really
enjoy fruit juices and vegetable juices.
And I always say,
well,
I mean at vegetable Jews,
yeah,
it's probably great,
but fruit juice man drinking a big glass
of orange juice,
you might as well be having a Coca Cola.
Yeah,
yeah,
I agree.
So our household has a,
a ban on smoothies and fruit juices and
sodas that have sugar in them.
God used to be able to go to like Jamba
juice and get one of those big Ole
smoothies and feel like you're doing
something good for your body.
I used to think,
yeah,
look it.
I got all this blueberries in there and
great stuff.
But meanwhile there's just a gang of
sugar in that thing.
Yeah.
I had an interesting thing that that
whole milk is actually potentially
better for you than the low fat.
You'll use less of it and it doesn't,
you know,
milk has some sugar in it.
It's also attached the fat,
right?
The whole milk has fat in it.
It's normal.
It's normal for your body to consume it
that way.
Right.
What?
What I want is I want my money back from
the nutritionists in the 19 seventies
and eighties.
I skipped eggs and Bacon.
It could have been eating that stuff.
While you remember that food pyramid
that used to be in the Dr Seuss books,
you're teaching kids to eat cereal,
you know it's so crazy and put
monitoring on your bread.
Oh,
that's the best stuff.
The best bad advice that they ever gave
vegetable oils,
which are fucking terrible for you.
All those disgusting vegetables,
safflower and corn oil,
all that stuff.
That's just terrible.
Terrible for you.
It is.
The other thing that that mothers used
to to some extent,
still tell their kids is don't go
hungry.
Have a snack.
Yeah.
I shouldn't say mother's parents in,
but in my family it's my wife.
She hates to see our kids go hungry at
all,
so it's always ate eight,
ate never be hungry and I'm there
saying,
no,
be hungry.
It's good for you.
And it's this tension with children
though,
because children are growing.
I always assume that children,
they should just eat whenever they're
hungry.
Well,
that's what stated.
I'm not sure if that's
the case often.
My son is somewhat.
My son isn't thin.
Put it that way and he'll be going out
the door and my wife will say,
have you had breakfast now?
I'm not hungry.
You have to eat something,
and I'm thinking,
no,
you got plenty of energy stored there.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah,
I mean it makes sense.
The only thing that I think of is that
when you're a young person,
your body is still actually growing and
developing as opposed to you and I.
If we're fasting,
it makes sense.
Right?
It makes sense.
You're,
you're giving your body a break and
there's all sorts of proven benefits to
that fasting process and well,
if you have a child who's overweight,
it isn't a bad thing to skip a meal.
No,
no.
It's not the.
The one,
the thing that worries me about children
that are overweight skipping a meal
though is that they're not as
disciplined and they're not so good
psychologically with struggling and
having know,
having hunger pangs and that you're
going to fuck their head up straight.
The teachers are probably be very angry
with me that the kids can't concentrate
well.
It's not just that.
Yeah,
the kids can't concentrate,
but I just,
I worry that it's in some way shape or
form abusive,
like to say,
hey,
you're overweight,
you need to lose weight.
Like I don't think they're like,
I don't think they're really designed to
go without the way way a grown adult
does.
These are my own perceptions.
I think that it's probably far better to
adjust their diet and if you've got a
kid just slowly get their body weight
down with exercise,
particularly with resistance training
and doing things that really burn off a
lot of calories and then just get them
off the sugar and then I think the way
it'll slowly slip off,
probably not even so slowly if you can
really get them off a significant sugar
binge.
Exactly.
So that's why I'm taking my son to the
gym as well.
I agree with that.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm just,
just to clarify because I don't want a
bunch of hate mail.
All I'm saying is don't force feed a
kid.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Don't force feed a kid.
Yeah,
I agree with that,
but I just think that kids,
they just get so fucking hungry,
man.
They get their little bodies are like
little hummingbirds.
No burning so much energy.
Yeah,
they do.
I'm amazing.
You don't take any other supplements?
Just vitamin D?
No multivitamins.
You don't want to like cover all your
bases?
No whole food supplements,
like vitamin A or a plant based
supplement that you can take during the
day?
No,
none of that.
No.
I've subscribed the idea that a lot of
it's expensive urine and Nope,
I'm testing myself so I know if I'm
deficient in something bad and all my
vitals or close to optimal.
So if something's out of whack out of
see it probably.
So you were saying you do things for the
government.
What did I say that,
you know,
you said that earlier you said I should
ask you on.
I didn't really did in for the show
started as was outside.
I was feeling frisky now that I've
thought about it,
a sign to go to jail.
I'll,
I'll talk about the.
A good idea to get you in trouble.
So let's pause and think this for a
moment.
There,
things that you can't talk about,
please don't.
Uh,
there's a lot to talk about.
I just have to make sure it's nothing
that's confidential,
but there's a lot of interesting stuff
going on on the planet.
There's,
there's areas of biodefense that are
pretty scary.
Also.
Some nations are apparently working on
using crispr and other gene editing
systems and modifying bugs that could
wipe out a few hundred million people
pretty quickly.
What do you do?
How do you detect that?
Um,
even the flu,
that's a massive by threat and it may
just be natural and that could wipe out
another 100 million people.
I can data exactly a century ago.
So,
um,
I work on that stuff.
I'm detecting viruses,
a,
wiping them out,
cleaning a room of DNA,
uh,
making sure that everything's clean.
Um,
so I'll give you an example so that the
navy seals came out to my lab,
um,
and they like to ask him how our group
to solve some hard problems.
And so the problem they set us on was
how do you kill anthrax?
I'm safely now,
right now,
it's very difficult to kill.
Of course,
when the anthrax letter was opened in
the Senate,
what was it,
a number of years ago?
It cost $25,000,000.
They had to seal it off and put hydrogen
peroxide all over.
Everything destroyed the computers.
So they're wondering how do you kill
anthrax safely so that you don't have to
be in a hazmat suit to do it.
And so what we came up with after
thinking about it for about a week was
we need a,
a biological solution,
not a chemical.
And so we found a,
an organism that,
uh,
where its whereabouts I cannot disclose,
but it's a very interesting organism
that grows at high temperature and it
destroys all bacterial and viral life.
Um,
and it wipes it out and it doesn't hurt
humans at all.
You as a,
or at least an animal studies,
you can breathe it in,
you can put it anywhere and it's fine.
So this is a,
a cocktail of enzymes that destroys the
microbes,
including anthrax.
So it doesn't have any effect on humans,
but what about the bacteria that lives
in our body,
our will,
we haven't eaten it yet.
What we're hoping to do is to do a
clinical trial soon on removing
biofilms.
So in the wounds of patients,
the problem that they,
the reason they don't heal very well,
especially these diabetic,
chronic wounds,
that by the way,
that every 10 minutes someone's losing a
limb,
thanks to that,
these biofilms,
you have to digest them off and do you
know how they do it right now?
They scrub them off,
it's horrific.
Then they cut the skin and they keep
cutting and cutting and eventually you
lose a limb.
This looks really promising in animal
studies that we should be able to not
just kill the bacteria in the wound,
which is a problem,
but get rid of that biofilm.
That's amazing.
So things like Murcia
staph infections,
exactly.
Be Able to stop it in its tracks before
it gets systemic,
right?
Spray that stuff on a cruise line for is
for the virus,
a norovirus.
Um,
even if it turns out to be that safe,
why not just wiped down schools?
Oh,
because I was worried about the negative
aspect,
like what's going to happen?
Like what's,
what's going to be the blowback,
right?
Like antibiotics is what's created
medicine resistant antibiotic for staph
infections.
Right,
right,
right.
Your mind always jumps to the worst
possible scenario.
Love it.
We'd make a good,
good team.
So I'm the,
I got a buddy cop movie.
Yeah,
let's do it.
Uh,
so we've tested,
does it induce antibiotic resistance?
And so far it's negative.
Mm.
Okay,
interesting.
Oh,
another thing I'll tell you.
So I work with a company that detects
organisms,
so we want to detect if there's another
virus coming across the planet.
So how do you do that quickly?
Um,
and how do you do it if you don't know
what you're looking for.
So we can take a drop of blood or a swab
off the table and we can see all the
organisms that are there.
We can do your microbiome,
but that's easy.
We can do a drop of blood,
will tell you all the bacteria and
viruses in there.
And it'll tell you how to kill it,
which is great for health care because
right now microbiology labs I've worked
in one.
I used to swap urine and poop on plates.
It was very glamorous.
That's how it still done.
That is,
that's 19th century,
early 20th century technology growing on
a plate.
Wait a few days,
see what grows.
But that's useless for diseases like
viruses and lyme disease,
lyme disease.
You know the one from ticks in your,
in your spine.
My daughter got lyme disease and she was
really sick.
She was losing her eyesight.
It was serious.
It got into her brain and the hospital
wouldn't give her the antibiotic because
I,
the tests weren't quick enough and they
wouldn't give her the antibiotic until
the test were positive for insurance
reasons.
And I said just Gimme that Gimme the DNA
of my daughter,
the spinal fluid,
I'll test it.
They wouldn't do that.
So I was furious.
So I spun out a company out of my lab
with some very smart,
um,
bioinformaticians mathematicians,
software engineers.
We built supercomputers to be able to do
this.
Teamed up with a guy in Stanford,
my friend,
I mentioned
him,
Carlos Bustamante.
He's the guy that uh,
did.
Uh,
oh,
maybe I shouldn't,
but he did a famous person's genome
recently.
Um,
his,
he'd been trained on mummy's,
um,
and he did Kennewick man.
And so this technology can be teamed up
with what I've done to be able to get
rid of all the human dna out of blood
sample,
leave the viruses,
lead the bacteria,
and then run that through a second super
computer,
all the DNA and tell you within probably
seconds eventually what it is.
So my daughter would,
would have a diagnosis within eventually
will be just 10 minutes instead of
waiting a week.
Wow.
Lyme diseases terrifying.
There are,
there are so many people that are
infected with it and I know personally
maybe 10 people that have it and a
couple that have had significant issues
with it that have lasted for years.
I know a guy who was hospitalized for a
full year on it lights.
It's really bad and it.
And it can hide as well.
That's the problem.
Yeah.
Um,
and it,
it wrecks joints.
And that thought,
a lot of countries have actually deny
that they have lung disease.
Australia's a good example.
People getting what seems to be lyme
disease and no one knows if it is or
not.
Give those samples to us.
We'll tell you what's in there.
Well,
it seems to be very difficult with
certain doctors for them to tell if they
don't see that bullseye infection.
Exactly.
So my daughter,
our daughter,
Natalie and middle daughter,
she didn't have a bullseye.
She had nothing.
The first thing we need to be.
Oh,
so it's inflammation around the bite of
the tick,
right.
And um,
and there's,
uh,
there's the actual bite and then there's
a circle on the outside of it.
And for whatever reason,
this occurs with lyme disease,
but oftentimes goes away quickly.
So if you bring a person in and they
have the lyme disease,
but they don't have that bullseye
anymore,
which is what happened to my friend
Steve Son,
he tried to tell them that it was lyme
disease.
They,
the doctors were incredulous.
They didn't believe him.
And it took until the kid had bell's
palsy at his face.
Exactly.
That's what happened in our family.
It's crazy.
And so I was bitten by a tick last year,
right behind the knee,
and it didn't form a bullseye.
Maybe I didn't give it time,
but it definitely was very painful
thing.
Um,
I could tell that there was something
going on.
It was really itchy and I went to the
pharmacy and I said,
can I have the antibiotic?
It's,
you know,
it's probably costs a few dollars for
the antibiotic.
And they said,
no,
we won't give it to you till we see a
bullseye and you need to bring the
ticket.
While I didn't bring the tick with me.
So again,
I'm the doctors and nurses.
Worst nightmare.
I wouldn't leave until they gave me the
antibiotic.
And I'm glad because I don't want to
wait till I give it to you.
They did.
I wasn't going to leave until I got it.
Uh,
but I don't want to wait a week,
you know,
I'm starting to lose my.
Did you get upset with them to say,
listen,
you dumb mother fuckers.
I'm super smart.
I work with jeans.
Uh,
no.
Not that occasion.
It's tempting.
No,
you can always say,
Hey,
I'm a professor at Harvard and then they
probably just really kick you out.
Yeah.
What do you say?
I mean,
how long did it take before they
listened to you?
Uh,
so I went through,
I basically started spouting biology so
that they knew their.
I knew something about it.
Oh,
it was about 15 minutes.
that's not bad.
He knew what to say.
It be there for days by Bro.
Trust me.
Right.
Let me draw you a picture of the tick.
Yeah,
I mean I would just think they'd want to
hand that stuff out quick with so many
people getting it.
It's so common.
I mean we looked at a map recently on
the podcast have lyme disease infections
across the east coast and the east coast
of United States.
Obviously that's where you live is just
a hotbed.
It's crazy.
It's everywhere.
Well,
it isn't an.
I've got friends on Cape Cod where it's
really prevalent,
really bad,
so bad that.
So they keep the antibiotic in their
kitchen drawer to Jesus and if you catch
it quick enough,
does it stop it in its tracks?
Yeah.
So the real problem is when it gets into
your bloodstream and you don't treat it
long enough or quick enough.
Exactly.
And so my,
my daughter needed a what's called a pic
line,
which has delivered the antibiotic to
straight into the heart.
Oh,
because they left it too long.
God,
I'd want to kill them and she didn't
have a ring,
a ring of inflammation.
But you knew I didn't.
I thought it was meningitis,
bacteria in the brain or something like
leukemia.
Was the other possibility,
those dirty fucking bugs,
what can be done to,
to somehow or another eradicate those
things.
Oh.
So,
um,
again,
one of my friends got a few friends
here,
uh,
she was working at Mit and she's
developed a way using the crispr system
to kill these,
as you say,
damn little fuckers.
Um,
and so there is possibly going to be the
first test of releasing a modified
organism,
the lyme organism,
to kill them off.
Wow.
MP,
you know that's going to cross some new
superbugs gonna kill everybody.
It's going to be like that.
A Brad Pitt movie,
the Zombie One,
World War z
might be,
but on the other hand,
we might all be saved from lung disease.
I would like that.
That would be great.
I just.
Where did lyme disease come from?
There was some conspiracy theory
website.
There was thinking that lyme disease was
some sort of a,
some sort of a biological weapon.
That's probably bullshit,
I'm sure.
But it came out.
It was in Lyme,
Connecticut,
right?
Wasn't that one of the first cases?
Yeah,
so that's a close enough to Harvard just
stayed away.
I thought you said Russians were buying
it.
Oh No.
I said conspiracy theory.
I didn't say it was Russian,
but as a biological weapon,
it's just an awful thing and that.
And now there's the.
I'm sure you're aware of the lone star
tick that gives people that I'm a Alpha
Gal.
D disease,
the one that makes you allergic to red
meat,
which is where.
Where was that before?
It's crazy to see these things morphing
and morphing and there are a lot of
bugs,
we don't know.
Somebody just published a few days ago
that they took surveys of the microbiome
on the skin,
mouth got across the planet,
different races,
different foods,
geographic geography,
and they have 100,000 different
organisms living on humanity
and most of them are unknown.
That's crazy.
Right?
Right.
And all they have to do is just more,
a little bit one way or the other way
and all of a sudden people were dropping
like flies.
Yeah.
And what's interesting is on the skin
and in the gut of people in India is
very different than what we have and the
different smells you might.
They probably think we smell bad,
but I know this because.
Well they're wrong.
Yeah.
Right.
Because I smelled like old spice,
but the,
these wounds there actually if you want
to kill the bacteria in a wound,
they're different in the wounds of
people in India than they are over here.
And.
Oh Wow.
That's interesting.
And obviously they have different diets
too,
so there's probably different things
they're used to consuming.
And so their gut bacteria is different,
right?
Everything's different.
The genomes are different.
So we need to map the globe to first
know what we're dealing with before we
can address.
It just seems like a never ending
struggle.
It,
it everyday is a struggle against the
natural world.
They want to kill us.
And he goes,
yeah,
everything,
the little things and the big things,
all of it with food.
So how much of your time gets consumed
with this kind of work?
Ah,
well it's all.
Everything is all consuming.
My,
my typical day is I got to go to a
company meeting going to the US
government.
I'm getting called by senator for an
update.
Uh,
so probably A.
Actually,
let me be formal about this.
Harvard University allows me to spend 20
percent of my time outside of the
university.
So it's 19 point nine.
So you have to cover your ass.
Is that?
We just did maybe,
but he tracks their time now anymore.
But I would think that with a guy like
you who's so you're,
you're,
you concentrate so much.
You're so focused on anti anti,
anti aging that having a gigantic
workload would seem to me to be a.
That would be an issue in terms of
overtaxing your system stressing
yourself out.
So nobody's ever asked me that and it's
a really good question.
Um,
but I'm,
I'm not really worried about dying.
I actually,
I'm not worried at all at all.
I know is,
you know,
it was a wolf in the room.
He's staring at you,
you know,
that'd be a grizzly death.
I'd probably not want that,
but I've been,
I thought I was going to die and on
airplanes before and I'm pretty calm
about that.
So I guess that's a good test.
But I do want to leave a legacy.
I want to be able to say the world's
better for me being on the planet.
Um,
and so that's why I do all this stuff.
I tried to protect the,
the humanity.
I try to protect nature.
I'm trying to help with food production.
Um,
my aging stuff is what I'm known for,
but I do a lot of this other stuff that
people don't know that.
So you'll,
your concern is anti aging,
you certainly want people to live
longer,
but you yourself are more concerned with
your work than you are with your own
personal life.
Oh,
100 percent.
My wife will tell you that the reason
that I look after myself as best I can
when I've got the energy is it would be
a bad look if I died from heart disease
tomorrow.
Yes.
The anti aging guy.
Well,
if you died from anything other than an
accident,
right?
Yeah.
All right.
So I'm trying to be a role model for
others.
Uh,
but you know,
if I,
if I died tomorrow,
that'd be fine with me.
I'd like to finish my work at least,
uh,
I would like to leave something behind.
But what I don't want to do is to be a
burden on my kids and my grandkids.
And so that's what I'm also trying to
prevent.
Yeah.
That would seem to me to be the real
final frontier of anti aging is folks
that are really,
really old because it seems like they
would be open to try almost anything.
And if you could bring them back,
that would be uber bizarre.
Right?
How far away do you think we are from
doing something like that?
Well,
it,
it often comes as a shock to people who
don't work on this that we're already
testing these molecules in clinical
trials on elderly people have been doing
that for a number of years now with some
positive results.
I'm over at Harvard.
We were giving any men and,
and another molecule called mit be 66.
Um,
what's the other one called?
My laundry so that the company's called
Metro Biotech and uh,
it makes Super Nad boosters and the drug
is called developmental drugs.
MIB,
dash six,
two six,
six,
two six.
Yeah.
And we're hoping that it will not just
have to get that alleyway somewhere.
Ah,
I got to go to some shady doctor with a
weird accent.
Uh,
that one,
uh,
that one we hope to get on the market in
about three years from now.
Really?
Yeah,
for,
for diseases FDA approved.
And so they're using it right now on old
folks are testing it,
tests for safety,
but we're also going to be testing
later,
uh,
energy.
Uh,
we can measure actually the Nad levels,
that molecule I mentioned,
we can measure that in their muscles and
we'll test if that worked.
Um,
and we'll,
we'll measure of course their endurance
because at the mice that we traded with
Nmn,
they just ran and ran and ran.
They actually broke the little treadmill
in my lap because they ran so far.
And you're giving it to them orally or
you're injecting into them?
Uh,
it's uh,
it's a little tablet.
They just put food,
put it in their fruit or something like
that.
All the mice.
Yeah.
Oh No,
I thought you're talking about humans in
the mice.
We put in their drinking water,
drink it fairly easy.
Wow.
And they have no idea,
no idea.
And in fact,
the people who are running the treadmill
have no idea which is which.
But we had mice running three kilometers
and then the machine stopped and I get a
text from the researcher,
Hey,
the machine broke.
And I said,
check the software and turns out
software was written to stop at three
kilometers because no mouse had run that
far before.
That's long.
And those are all nice.
Don't forget,
these are mice that are the equivalent
of a 65 year old human.
Really?
Yeah.
And we figured out why they run further.
This isn't just try it and see.
We figured out that,
that the lining of the blood vessels
needs an id as you get older,
but they needed all the time.
But as you get older you don't have
enough net.
So the Nmn replenishes that and allows
the blood vessel lining to respond to
exercise and even grow blood vessels if
you don't exercise.
And so those mice,
they ran and ran and ran,
that didn't get lactate build up as
much.
I just didn't feel tired.
So lactic acid buildup.
Right.
Wow.
So muscle fatigue would be different.
Uh,
well they didn't seem to get that
either.
Wow.
Was just better blood flow.
We even pinched off an artery and the
body responded much better to restore
restoring blood flow,
which would be great for patients who
have a heart attack.
Whoa.
Now with human beings,
what has been the most dramatic result?
Uh,
that's a hard question because a lot of
it's early stage.
Um,
we developed a molecule that seemed to
effectively treat a disease called
psoriasis,
which is the information.
Has that.
Yeah.
So that,
that,
that worked,
and that's a molecule,
that's something you apply to the skin.
It was a,
it was a pill actually.
Yeah.
How does that work?
What does it doing?
A.
So it's an activator of one of these
sirtuins that we found in yeast
originally.
These are two and protective enzymes in
the body and there antiinflammatory.
And so that worked well against that
disease.
So psoriasis has something to do with
inflammation.
It is an inflammatory disorder.
Yep.
Um,
are all autoimmune disorders Antifa or
inflammatory based disorders?
I believe so.
Really interesting.
Hey,
[inaudible],
I have a little ego.
You don't see the little spots on my
skin where I don't have any pigment.
It's genetic.
My grandmother had it,
my grandmother sister had it.
Um,
I wonder if that would help me
a.
yeah,
I really couldn't say.
What's it called again?
Which one?
Third drug that was tested.
Um,
it has an srt.
Twenty one.
Oh four.
And this is the stuff that worked on
psoriasis in a small study in New York.
Now what other,
um,
what other things had really a dramatic
results on humans?
Well,
we're not there yet.
We don't have traumatic results.
Is there anything promising results on
humans or than Nmn and yes,
there are there.
So this mtor,
I mentioned earlier where the drug
rapamycin,
which is too dangerous to try on normal
people.
That drug has been tried on elderly
people and it boosted their immune
system in the same way that you see with
calorie restricted mice and so that that
was an,
an early signal that you might be able
to reverse aspects of aging and the
elderly with that truck.
Now,
with older folks,
one thing you see is the body doesn't
produce Collagen as much.
Your skin gets lax and starts to sag.
What,
what things could be done to mitigate
that I'm eating besides botox and stuff.
Well,
Botox doesn't really do.
That just freezes your face like aware
as well.
So I'm asked that a lot.
Will it?
I'm David,
don't worry about protecting cancer,
heart disease,
Alzheimer's.
So I look better.
Can I look better?
Yeah.
Right?
Uh,
and the,
the answer is that a,
we don't know,
a B,
we're working on it.
We have,
we work with a cosmetic company that so
far so good.
Um,
but I don't endorse products.
That's not me.
But also what's interesting is that
these mice,
at least they stay younger looking as
well.
They don't just live longer.
Um,
so this hope that something,
the skin is a big organ.
Okay.
So,
right.
Why wouldn't it stay young just like the
rest of the body?
Well,
it certainly indicative of whether or
not a person's healthy,
right?
If you see someone in their skin is
really saggy and fucked up looking,
you assume that persons not healthy.
Right?
Um,
and actually a lot of us scientists
believe that how you look is actually
pretty good indicator of your biological
age.
Speaking,
biological age,
there's a been a breakthrough the last
few years being able to tell your
biological age.
I'm one part's done by inside tracker
looking at blood biomarkers,
but there's a new one called the DNA
cluck.
You heard about this?
Yes.
I have a.
So a colleague of mine is well known for
it,
Steve Horvath,
and what it is is uh,
so you know,
how DNA I said is changing over time and
the epigenome is changing.
So these are like scratches on the
clock,
uh,
on,
on the DVD.
We think we know what those scratches
are and how to remove them and what they
are a little chemicals that bind to the
DNA called methyls.
And the older you get the momentum you
accumulate on your DNA and we can read
that with machine and we can very
precisely say you're roughly this age,
but you're actually older or younger for
your chronological age
and now we think we can reverse that.
Wow.
How long do you think you are away from
doing that?
Being able to reverse that.
Well,
that's that glaucoma treatment that
we're looking at.
I would like to see,
take someone like a wealthy Mel Gibson
type character and just shoot them up
with everything,
like just get someone who's willing to
give you a full run of them and run it
like a,
some sort of a science fiction movie.
Tell you what,
I'll do it if you'll employ me because
I'll be kicked out of my job.
I'm sure you would.
But man,
I mean it just seems like there's so
many promising things.
It would be really fascinating if you
could document that you could take one
person.
It was like a,
a wealthy man in his mid to late
sixties.
Well,
there's this forage element in anti
aging.
In fact,
I don't even like the term anti aging.
It's what do you like a longevity
research?
Um,
we're,
we're about to announce maybe this a
sneak preview for everybody,
an academy for Aging Research of the top
20 scientists in the world of banding
together to,
to,
uh,
produce white papers and opinions.
Um,
but yet we call it longevity research.
And so anti aging is,
is more that the botox and that kind of
stuff,
that we don't want anything to do it
right.
But that's nonsense.
It's not really anti aging.
You're not doing anything about age and
you just freezing your skin's.
What doesn't move?
That is.
That to me is one of the weirder things,
especially with men.
When I see a man,
his forehead doesn't move.
I want to smack him in the mouth.
Like,
what's wrong with you sir?
How dare you smack it just,
it's not,
it's a,
it's not like botox or fillers or any of
those things.
You're not doing anything for your
health or your actual real vitality.
You're just weirdly doing something
cosmetic,
right?
Yes,
you are.
And so I think the defense is you feel
better if you look better
psychologically it might help.
I don't think they look better though.
They just look different.
Yeah.
Well that's the problem.
It is true.
Um,
yeah,
I,
I don't spend a lot of time thinking
about the cosmetic industry for obvious
reasons.
I'm trying to save humanity and,
and improve the planet.
Um,
I actually,
I do think we will,
we will be judged as a,
uh,
as a species if an alien came down and
they said,
you're shooting botulism in your face
fries.
Right,
exactly.
You are a weird,
you're not allowed in the club have
advanced species.
Well that would only be one thing that
we were weird from.
But what would,
what would they ask you?
They,
well,
they'd ask us,
have you figured out the speed of light?
They had asked me why I have drawings
all over my arm.
No,
no.
They might appreciate art maybe,
but like they'd be like,
why didn't you just get it and then just
wash it off or something.
You have to get it drilled in your skin
that's coming.
But I think one of the most important
questions they'd ask to tell if we are
an advanced nation or pants species is,
have you figured out aging yet?
Right.
Deterioration.
And we're so pathetic as a species.
Our answer would be,
you mean that's a thing.
You can do something about that and
they'll come back in a thousand years.
Well,
I mean there's got.
How many people do you think worldwide
are working in your field?
Uh,
so in terms of leading labs,
there's about 20,
30,
broadly.
There's a probably a few hundred labs
and other,
all essentially the same field of study.
They're all working with the same
molecules and the same parameters.
I know that not everyone works with
molecules,
but what I can tell you is we get
together in conferences and we talk
about discovering new chain that extends
lifespan and a new molecule that's
working in mice or sometimes in humans,
but it's a big field now.
It's grown.
And when I started it was the backwater
of biology and oxidants,
etc. I was very lucky to start when it
was really small and stick it out.
Those faIr amount of criticism in those
days.
what,
how,
so like that.
It was like a lot of my friends,
my supervisor said I was insane for
working on aging.
That's not a thing.
That's not biology really.
Yeah.
Wow.
Wait,
how long ago was this?
uh,
so I came to the us from sydney in 1995.
Went to mit and the scientists in the
lab that I joined,
lenny guarantee's lab,
they two students had just started
working to figure out why east get old
and I joined as the third senior person
to join and all the other people in the
lab.
There were about 18,
19 people.
They said,
you are nuts.
Lenny's lost his mind.
He's working on aging.
That's not a thing.
You should be working on what we do,
which is understanding how genes are
regulated.
So I called up my mom and I said,
I think I've made a big mistake here.
I thought this was the thing and the guy
and everyone here says he's nuts.
Meanwhile,
you were right.
Well,
you gotta take some risks in life.
That's one lesson.
Yeah,
but that's an interesting one,
right?
Because you were a young fellow.
He didn't really.
Totally.
No.
It was pretty lucky because I'm in
Australia.
Right.
I don't know what people are saying
about this lab up there.
Oh,
but always been fascinated with aging
since I was four.
Well now though,
with all the promising new discoveries,
I mean they.
They have to be eating crow as it were.
Talk to those people.
I go,
hey,
fuck face.
I was right.
No,
don't call him up in the middle of the
night.
Drunk.
No,
I definiTely forgive people too much and
had some pretty big enemies along the
way,
but I try to be nice.
Is it because of research and this sort
of scientific work is so competitive?
Yeah,
it is.
It isn't.
There's this belief that someone's
success is your failure.
It's not really that that is the case,
but it exists in show business too.
It's so weird sort of a mindset.
It's a very limiting mindset.
Right,
and also,
and this may be true in hollywood,
in science,
if you come up with a new idea when
you're young,
you're young turk and you're upsetting
the status quo on the thomas kuhn's book
on structure
of scientific revolutions was just had
it had it right.
He wrote in the sixties that chemistry
and physics,
but it applies to biology that if you
come up with a new theory that's that
disruptive,
the current leaders will attack you and
it's a period of chaos and you just have
to get through it,
and fortunately I'd read kuhn's book and
I knew that this was normal,
but a lot of people around me were
saying,
oh no,
if people are saying we're wrong and
it's controversial,
we don't want to be controversial.
I'm like,
controversies,
great,
let's.
Let's do more of that,
and if it's not controversial,
I don't Want to do it.
That is interesting.
Do you think that's because the people
who are the old guard or upset,
they didn't fight it themselves or they
upset that your new findings will make
their work look irrelevant?
Yes.
It's probably a bit of both,
but mostly it's,
it's that they're worried that their
lives will be have been in vain if what
you're working on is not true.
Right?
Yeah.
There's a.
there's an amazing documentary on the
sphinx where these geologists are
talking about some of the water erosion
outside the area of the sphinx and
they're saying this points to the fact
that construction was thousands of years
older than they thought and you see this
one egyptologist freaking out.
He's freakIng out.
Like what evidence,
what evidence of this culture you're
talking about?
Like,
because apparently it would have
predated the known dates of 2,500 bc,
but if it made it like 7,000 years older
than that because it would have to be
back when there was rainfall in the nile
valley and you could see this guy's ego
kicking it because he was a professor.
He had been teaching egyptology and he
was freaking out.
Instead of examining this evidence like
wow,
like talking to this geologist who
studies rocks and erosion,
who's really steadfast is a boston
university geologists,
dr robert schoch and you know he's
saying this is evidence of water erosion
and he's showing it and he even showed
it to a bunch of other geologists and
they all agreed and this guy,
this egyptologist and this documentary
was freaking out.
I was like,
wow.
That's what happens when you think your
whole life's work is horseshit.
Yeah.
It can be a blow to the ego.
I haven't lived through that yet.
It's probably coming,
but what I've noticed is that the really
successful scientists and people in life
just embrace change and that kInd of
have to.
I mean,
it doesn't mean that that guy is a
loser.
It just means he was acting on incorrect
information based on what they knew
before.
I mean,
it should embrace it and say,
look,
well we know certain things were built
at 2,500 bc,
like the great pyramid.
That's been pretty clearly established,
but it looks like there was some ancient
structures that were there even before
then.
Let's now we have new things to study if
they don't look at it that way though.
Yeah.
See the problem with,
with how biology and actually most facts
a toilet,
uh,
theories are taught is that there's a
textbook and that's the bible
equivalent.
Uh,
whaT I try to teach my students is,
can you please just forget everything
you just learned and what's important to
know is that most things we think we
know are not,
they're going to change over time.
Old Theories change.
Newton was wrong,
but he helped us get here,
uh,
expect that we only know point.
Oh,
one percent of,
of what we need to figure out and a lot
of what we think we know is wrong
anyway.
So even if you have the greatest theory,
expect that it will be overturned,
but you can at least cherish the fact
that you've helped us get to that point.
Because without newton we wouldn't have
quantum physics.
Well,
for someone like me hearing you say
that,
it's very promising and it's,
it's,
it's very encouraging.
but I always thought that scientists
were always going on just data,
like the,
all they cared about was data,
all they cared about is what is correct.
And that was what was crucial.
That's what's important.
This is what theY talk about.
This is what the study,
when I found out that scientists would,
would ignore information or use their
own personal biases against information
or attack research because it somehow
negates what they've done is very
disheartening for someone who's not a
scientist.
And you go,
oh no,
the egos in science too,
right?
It's disheartening as a scientist,
I can tell you there Were,
there was a time of great change in the
aging field where we discover genes
control aging and molecules like where's
virtual could extend health and
lifespan.
It Was,
it was brutal.
You,
I'd get up and I give a speech and
someone to say,
you're wrong.
This is crap.
And where are they now?
Do you call them up in the middle of the
night?
Uh,
this dilemma,
you
have a couple of glasses of wine.
Yeah.
Well,
I think the secret to success in life is
actually just existing for long enough
and all your enemies to fall away.
Well,
they die.
They're not into anti aging.
Yeah.
Looks like shit and I can't walk
anymore.
Just have to outlive your enemies.
That's an easy way.
That must have been a tough time though.
For you as a young man and you know,
you're,
you're hearing this from these
established scientists and part of you
must have been like thinking like
cheese.
Are they right?
SUre.
You have to entertain the possibility
that you're wrong,
that that's what we do.
Uh,
but you go back to the lab and you
retest It.
So I went through a really brutal period
in my career where we had data,
we interpreted it,
we published it in the top journals and
it was about how [inaudible] virtual
works on that sir to an enzyme that I
mentioned.
And pfizer came out with a paper that
said it's all wrong.
And I had people call me Up Saying,
you know,
it was nice knowing you.
I'm really sad for you,
but it's over.
Yeah.
Bad luck.
And so I went back to the lab,
we had some data already from yearS
before,
which I knew were interesting and it
took another thing for years to get to
the bottom of it.
But it turns out in the end I was right.
But there were days when I said screw
humanity,
I couldn't be bothered getting out of
bed if this is how I'm going to be
treated for trying to devote my life to
the betterment of people's lives.
It's tough.
I'm not,
I anybody who's
in a position in their career like that
has to have gone through really hard
times.
It's just discouraging from a non
scientist who relies on people like you.
For someone like me who relies on the
folks like you out there doing the hard
work that you would face,
that sort of.
I guess the best way to describe it
would be ignorance.
Well,
it's okay for scientists to challenge a
theory.
That's what I did and what everybody is
trained to do.
Uh,
but to do it in such a public end and
vish controversial,
it Was vicious.
It was definitely vicious.
Even the words they used were vicious,
uh,
which is really hurtful,
but,
but they're wrong.
Well,
they might've been right or wrong.
I call them up middle of the night.
You dumb motherfucker.
The person who published that paper,
I do think about a meeting that person,
again,
a droid careers.
it's not just,
it's tough.
You can run out of money.
Your students go away.
Sure.
That was happening to my left.
We went down to four people.
I mean,
and what was the high?
Uh,
I mean these days I'm.
But what about before then?
It was about 80 slash 20.
And you went down to four.
Four.
So it was looking bad.
Oh yeah.
People had written me off.
Holy shit.
but you were right.
When he got to push forward,
it's you got to get lean because you're
not goIng to get government funding for
awhile because people think that you're
a failure.
God damn,
that's crazy.
Well,
science is not for the faint of heart,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
Boy.
Skin,
thick skin.
A stubbornness only.
Only those survive.
What was the turnaround
like?
Was there a moment where it turned
around and moved in our favor?
Yeah,
there was.
There was one day when it.
When it all changed,
so the earlier data,
so what data driven the early data was
that the enzyme we can we could mutate
or change the enzyme so that it wasn't
going to be activated by research and we
found that mutation now that just
technically or non tickling technically
means that we could change the enzyme in
a way it wouldn't work,
so we didn't put that nonworking enzyme
into a cell and now we have a mouse that
doesn't work and we give it resveratrol
virtual and if it.
If it works,
it means I'm wrong.
If it doesn't work and it's blocked by
that change in the enzyme will probably
right and that's what we did.
But the real,
the real change was that there was a
company that I started that was making
drugs,
the one that a cure or at least seemed
to cure psoriasis and they had made
these very synthetic molecules that were
not related to the plant molecule
residual.
And so I said to myself and to the
student who was working on it,
they're very brave student if,
if the change in that enzyme also blocks
the drug,
then we're onto something because that
means two separate groups working on
separate types of molecules,
different people,
different systems all get blocked by
this one little change in the enzyme,
then we're right.
And,
and so he walked over to the company,
got the molecule,
throw it on the enzyme and it didn't
work on the mutant.
And that was me a rejoicing because I
could say there was a universal
activation mechanism on this one enzyme,
rich virtual works,
uh,
the molecules at the company work.
And now there's an interesting thing
that just came out from Spain that
metformin,
the diabetes drug may actually work the
same way as these other molecules by
activating our favorite enzyme,
the sirtuin wow.
And how,
how much time were you in the dark
lands?
It was a couple of years of hell,
right?
If it gets so bad because you've got
this tight knit group of scientists and
you have lab meetings and you present
your results and usually you're very
supportive trying to help.
I had one guy saying to my student,
david doesn't always talking about you
shouldn't work on this.
It's been proven wrong.
He was dead against me in my own lab.
I'm paying your salary and it's okay to
be constructive,
but vicious within my own group.
What?
Suffice to say,
he wasn't in my group for that long.
Wow.
Now this other guy that used all these
other vicious words about you.
Where's he at now?
Not sure.
I would know.
Now I don't have time to look back on
your iphone.
You're nicer than me.
Yeah.
You know what?
I'm in science because it's very
collaborative and you're often.
Your enemies are reviewing your own
work.
If you build up too many enemies,
you won't survive,
so it's definitely healthier approach.
I'm sure I probably would do exactly
what you did,
but it still has got to be beautiful to
come out on the other end and be proven.
Correct,
and actually be at the forefront of
these emerging technologies.
Uh,
well,
it,
it is an arm rest on any laurels,
but the,
what I do is I pause and I remember how
hard it was to get here and how
fortunate I am to have made it this far
and I'm working with hundreds of
collaborators around the world to make
this come true.
This idea that we can really treat aging
and prevent deterioration.
So I'm blessed.
I have an app on my phone that I've
helped engineer.
What's that?
It's called lucy liu a.
And where does that?
Uh,
well it's,
it's a little company that we bought in
New York and uh,
nurses and dentists use it to pass
medical information around,
but we use it to share information
between scientists around the world and
coordinate activities between companies
that started.
Yeah.
So I,
you know,
I think I mentioned to you that I've
started a few companies.
What I'm trying to build our companies
that are the 21st century version of a
pharma company that is actually has a
decent reputation in the world.
I think it's pharmaceutical companies,
whether it's deserved or not,
have a pretty bad rap.
I'm trying not to fall into that trap,
but I'm also trying to use 21st century
technology to not become too
bureaucratic as well within the
organization.
That's what the luma app offers us.
You were also talking,
I don't know if you could talk about
this before the podcast,
about how you have to make sure you have
zero conflicts of interest.
Yeah,
it's hard.
So I don't,
I don't sell any supplements.
I don't endorse anything.
Um,
no products.
But if you look on the internet,
if you google david sinclair and nad or
aging,
you'll see that people put my name and
my face all the time on their websites
and I get questions every day.
Every morning I wake up.
Which product are you endorsing?
And so I have to be extremely careful.
So do you have to have your lawyer
contact those companies?
Tell them to take your name?
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a fair amount of money always
sending out cease and desist letters,
but I have to do it.
My reputation is everything.
And also want to be able to have
opinions on these molecules without
someone accusing me of doing it for
profit.
That's what I would think would be
because of anybody could point to that
and say,
hey,
he endorses this because he's making
money.
Yeah.
That's what would be.
Yeah,
that would be the thing that means
especially because most people aren't
going to do real research and developed
a nuanced understanding of your work and
what you're doing and what it means and
how long you've been studying it.
They go,
oh,
he's doing it because he's making money.
I'm done
now.
Right.
Well,
you know,
I've made a fair amount of money in my
life.
My first company,
even though it wasn't the major
shareholder,
was sold for north of 700,
$20,000,000.
So that money I'm not immune to,
but I do reinvest almost all of it.
Actually all of it.
My wife will tell you into new ventures
to change the world.
So the lyme disease company and the miv
66 company metro.
These are funded initially by me.
Now the conflict arises because I'm
studying these molecules in the lab and
I'm on the board of directors and
advising these companies as chairman,
vice chairman,
the only way around that as a scientist
that we,
uh,
that we have is our defenses.
We disclose everything.
So initially I would disclose it to the
government and to harvard.
All scientists have to do that,
but I've gone a step further just to try
and beat ultra transparent with the
public.
And so I have a website.
If you go to my lab's website,
you'll see everything that I do and,
um,
and hopefully that's a protection from
being accused of being biased.
But what I definitely do in my lab is I
say to the students,
if you get a whiff that I'm doing
anything biased,
I would,
I wouldn't do anything consciously,
but maybe there's some unconscious bias,
let me know,
let the university know and we'd find.
But I've been doing this for 25 years.
Uh,
I think I'm pretty good at putting a,
a wall between the two.
Um,
and the other thing that I want
everybody to know is in the,
we do very basic research.
We try to understand the fundamental
reasons why we age and how to reverse
it.
The companies are more worried about how
we're going to do a clinical trial,
which is very different worlds,
so they don't overlap much.
now when you want to bring something to
try or something to the market or do you
want to try somethIng on people?
What's the process like?
Say if you have some sort of a molecule
that you want to try out on people,
what is that process?
Uh,
so it's a few years have often making it
better molecule.
But let's say you've done that work now.
You spent a year testing it on at least
two different species.
I'm usually a rodent,
a mouse and a dog and,
but you try to do everything you can
before that to make sure it's not going
to be unsafe.
Testing on cells and other things that
are not living or at least not,
not to feel anything,
but the fda food and drug administration
of the us requires.
If you can make a drug,
you have to test it on at least two
different species,
so that's what you do and then it's you
go into what's called phase one,
which is safety testing takes one to two
years.
Phase two is what we call efficacy,
which is does it really work?
Potentially,
so you test that on 50 to 100 people.
Maybe it works,
maybe it doesn't.
Most things fail.
If it looks good,
then you go into phase three,
which is 50 to $200,000,000 worth of
experiments and testing it on hundreds
of patients and if that goes well,
then you apply to the fda to be licensed
to sell a drug.
So the amount of money that it must cost
to bring something to mr years open
neural or who?
It's.
It's hard.
It must be staggering.
It's staggering to raise that much money
and that that's one of the reasons that
these big numbers come up.
Often we have to tap the public markets
to be able to afford it because a
typical drug will cost hundreds of
millions of dollars.
Some drugs have failed after
$700,000,000 investment.
Oh yeah.
But,
but look at the upside.
If we're successful at having a drug
that treats aging
will treat a disease like diabetes
first,
but then it could become the best
selling drug of all time if it's proven
safe.
Who,
who wouldn't want to have a drug that
could protect them from all these major
diseases?
Yeah.
But how much would something where you'd
have to sell it for so much wanted to
make makeup for all the research money,
right?
Is how it works.
That's how it usually works.
But for the first time I'm,
I'm in control of many of these
companies and I have a large say in them
at least.
And I as an individual,
um,
and pledging that we won't do that.
We're not going to put our prices up to
what the market can bear.
We want.
This is a gift to the world.
And so that's a very different approach.
And it's one of the reasons that I've
enlarged part,
used my own money to do these things so
I can have that say and do what's right
for the planet.
So when you do do that,
how you decide
how much something costs based on the
ability to just maintain the company?
Well,
yeah,
we have to be profitable,
otherwise it'll,
it'll goes away,
right?
Um,
but not to.
The point of extortion note is there's a
nice middle ground and what?
Right.
You don't want to be like that guy that
went to jail for the aids drug.
What's set assholes name,
you know,
that kid you squarely cotton's
currently,
uh,
you know,
I've had very different view and I'm
hoping that we'll have a new type of
pharmaceutical company emerging out of
what we're doing.
That's amazing,
right?
Because pharmaceutical drug companies
are always thought as being a devil.
Meanwhile,
They're responsible for so many things
to keep people alive as well.
But because of the fact they're
connected to things like oxycontin and
fentanyl and things that kill people.
And it's been proven that there are
certain unscrupulous drug companies that
have pushed things out there that they
know have negative effects because they
knew they could profit from it.
Right.
Well,
not everybody's ethical,
but as long as I have a say in these
companies,
they will be ultra ethical.
You've got to make sure that you stay
alive.
They're going to try to take you out,
bro.
Hell yeah.
Uh,
I don't know about that,
but take control of the company.
I've found prophets.
I found like minded investors for the
first time.
That's amazing too.
I mean,
how,
how have you managed to cultivate that
relationships?
It's harder than going with a pitch to a
capitalist,
but,
uh,
it's mainly meeting the right people.
I want to say that they're on board too.
I don't want to just have somebody who's
out to make a profit.
Right.
But you still can make a profit
profitable but don't go crazy.
Right.
Help the world.
Yeah.
And so we just recruited to one of the
boards of the company,
someone from a consumer company,
which is a strange choice,
right?
But this is a person who's done right at
that company for the world.
I'm a company that used to make just
some,
uh,
because you want products that weren't
healthy and he turned that around and
that's the kind of person I want to work
with.
Who cares about the pLanet more than
they care about the ultimate profit.
That's awesome man.
Listen,
keep me.
Keep me in the loop.
I want to know what's going on and I'm
gonna.
Try all these things that you said.
So I'm going to go out.
I'm going to buy some nmn.
I'm going to buy some resveratrol.
I gotta find a quack that's willing to
prescribe me.
Metformin.
Got shade.
We'll talk later.
Um,
and then the other stuff,
the srt 21.
Oh,
four.
That stuff.
Where would one get that?
That's experimental.
That's probably the hardest one to help
you with.
You need to pay somebody off.
Um,
anything else I need to know about?
Said it.
Have you had you just 23 and me
basically,
you know,
I haven't.
Is there more extensive versions of it
than that?
There are.
I mean,
they're a few thousand bucks to you hold
genome and we can do that,
but I don't think you'll learn a lot
more mainly because we're ignorant as to
what the other staff's doing.
Right.
It was pretty interesting though as far
as finding out about my ancestry and
where my relatives come from.
Yeah,
it's a good start.
I learned some really interesting things
too about my origins and I'm carrying
cystic fibrosis gene and whatever.
Wow.
But what's cool is now emerging,
you can merge that data with the inside
tracker data and have this ultimate
personal angel for health that will,
uh,
hopefully one day be on all of us that
we've got the personal tracking device.
IT'll tell us if there's something going
wrong.
If you are a cancer cell detected,
go get that eliminated.
It's crazy these days.
We have to wait till there's an actually
a tumor that's making you sick before
you actually go to the doctor.
An actual issue.
Well now I know why you're so excited
about the future.
So you have an inside track on this.
Yeah.
Front row seat.
And I'm glad to share a little bit with
your listeners.
Oh,
thank You.
I really,
really appreciate it.
Tell the listeners and the viewers what
your website is.
I just have a harvard website,
but I will be.
I'll tweet about this.
I'm launching a website for a book that
I planned that I'm writing now and it's
going to come out later this year.
We hope when it comes out,
come on back.
I would love to give an update.
Thank you,
david.
Really,
really appreciate it.
That's it.
Bye everybody.